[Music]
all right here we are again
so so weird no [ __ ] [ __ ] for that but
whatever
you were laughing at sandra what does it
say i can't read it sandra knows that a
girl can noodle too
okay yeah
of course girls can also noodle yeah oh
my god
david june says tom got my shirt in
yesterday looks badass
you wore it to work and people were
loving it yeah which one was it which
one was it the big
piston one yeah we just met that other
day didn't we wow that was quick
what day was it remember what design it
was it might have been a big plastic one
i can't remember either yeah we did
because we did like a [ __ ] tunnel at
once
yeah and uh she must be talking about
she must be talking about uh like
catfish
yeah catfish no but yeah i don't know
what got her on that subject
a long time since i was talking about i
don't think it was i think it was just
like
i don't think it was the last show but
it was only a couple shows ago it might
have just been like the friday night
show
all right it was recent it was recently
i can't remember everything i [ __ ]
say
that's true yeah not when i was sober
[Laughter]
drunk i remember everything i don't know
about that
do you have some kind of like opposite
thing where it's like you're drunk and
you remember everything everyone else
forgets [ __ ] when they're drunk
[Laughter]
oh my goodness all right it's wednesday
everybody
and look i cut my hair yesterday now i
got like i got a hawk
yeah i cut it i didn't put it all the
way up yeah i did t
i did tease it and fluff it a little bit
beside this side and show them this side
let me sew this side
yeah which one's my better side well
neither they're the same neither side's
good
not my hair my face
[Laughter]
not really everyone's got a better side
yeah that's not the first time i've had
my hair like this i used to have it all
shaved
underneath up to my crown it's a mohawk
with a chelsea yeah
on the front she didn't want me to shave
it right here i just was just gonna do
it with sideburns
well remember i used to have uh just
this little bit right here
i don't know if we were doing the show i
used to have just that yeah and then
this was all shaved
but i don't know i thought it made my
head look bigger i don't think so
that looks good though they both look
good i mean you know
and i felt like it would be good to even
though i don't have to work like a
regular job anymore
think [ __ ] um i still thought it would
be good to be able to just like put it
down and nobody would be able to see the
shady part
although honestly i'm still i'm i'm
undecided whether i want to shave
because now it's like a
it's a classic kind of mohawk where i
still have hair here
yeah but i'm kind of thinking i might go
back to just it all being shaved
okay it's all the way around i'm not
really i don't know i haven't decided it
looks good like that
if you ask me oh it's not a big
difference that's only that's only an
inch deep
an inch wide yeah i mean we didn't leave
much back here it tapers into a point
yeah that's what i'm saying it's just
because it's so much cooler
and that's then there's like less hair
to fall out and be all over the bathroom
floor that we have to
move up it's funny how much hair that
was just just those two sides
i couldn't believe it well i could
believe it but then i'm always like
alarmed when i see it
like yeah just this little bit that he
cut off it was just like this it was
this
big ball like that i have so much hair
you guys i don't know where the [ __ ] it
comes from
i cut it out of your head well duh i
know that you know what i mean
yeah it's just that like every time i
wash it every time i brush it every time
something like that like a whole bunch
of it falls out
and my hair is just like all over this
[ __ ] house seriously it's like not
even funny
uh but it never seems to get any thinner
all right
you know what i'm saying so i don't know
maybe from now on i'll keep it shaved it
is like much
i mean it's a pain having to like
maintain it because it looks shitty when
it grows out
but it's kind of better than having just
this big [ __ ]
yeah heavy lump of hair
david's saying it was the tyrell shirt
same one this is yeah okay that's one of
my favorite new designs
that did come out nice yeah it's good in
the club i bought it to the club several
times yeah
i see this is nice necklaces thank you
yes yes
it's two different ones that's just says
let the snattings begin those
shenanigans gonna happen i'm just
getting shenanigans
we were just uh we were we were just
playing with the blood pressure
machine like before it started yeah tina
said that [ __ ] haircut looks like
crosstalk goth
queen and a wakandan warrior s
all right i'll take it but yeah like i
said i've had it kind of like this
before but
yeah i don't know we were talking about
it at the club on friday or saturday and
i was like i gotta do something with
this [ __ ] mop it's like driving me
[ __ ] crazy
we started season four spartacus it's
good
it's good man yeah we only we got we
watched the first episode and then part
of the second one and then i fell asleep
and it was just i didn't mean to fall
asleep i was sitting up against all
those zillion pillows
we have yeah and i was just like and
then like i woke up to tom being like
well hey what did what they did today
and like asking me something about a
plot i'm like dude i fell asleep i have
no idea what you're talking about
like i missed like a bunch of stuff like
what you said
when i woke up you were asking i said
what's she doing to him
all right look you asked if she was
sounding him and i was just like
what did i miss i think she was holy
crap i missed something good yeah
they introduced you to marcus crassus or
crassus and and he these are real
figures out of out of [ __ ] roman
history they played a big uh
they played a big part in the roman
civil wars later on they brought
julius caesar into power but uh
crassus shows up and uh they kind of
establish him as a [ __ ] good
as a good character he was he was kind
of a good dude he was just a rich dude
of lowly birth who [ __ ] bought his
way into the royal class basically
and that's that's really who he was um
and then um who shows up as a young
guy's julius caesar or julius gaia
caesar
and he's got a beard and everything
because he's just come back from his
long war up and i guess it was thrace
where was it no it wasn't race it was uh
[ __ ] they mentioned it i was dozing off
yeah they mentioned which war it was it
wasn't it wasn't gall
but he but he's getting a kind of an
opposite position
he's got this badass [ __ ] family name
supposedly you know like descent
descendant from [ __ ] venus and [ __ ]
his mama descended from venus in his
death yeah he's kind of a deified
dude he was broke they didn't have any
money you know
and uh he or he had money and kind of
lost it
but his his family was poor
anyway um
there now anyway there's one part where
you know julius is [ __ ]
trying to sling his dick around like he
did that's he was like that you know
it was like that when he was young he
was like he was a dick slinger he was
dicks
he had that [ __ ] it was a 45 caliber
[ __ ] dick
in the holster and he'd sling that
shucks [ __ ] her out
anyway he uh he he would uh
he made a move on [ __ ] guys's [ __ ]
slave
girl who in the bath tub you know okay
see i must have dozed off during that
scene
like right before that because i don't
remember that crisis comes in
hold on hold on and he goes oh i didn't
know she meant anything do you type a
deal you know it turns out
that's his girlfriend and he's [ __ ]
he likes her more than he likes the wife
but um later later on his dad deploys
uh gaius or excuse me crassus [ __ ]
has to go off
and deploy and deploy his army and
thinking julius is
sitting on a chair and he's got some
slave girl down there and she's got a
[ __ ] long
skinny blade of some sort and she's down
in between his legs doing something they
don't show what he's doing he's back
there
kind of like ah oh like a joint it would
pay
and you see some blood dribbling on the
ground but you don't know exactly what
what she's sucking doing that's what it
sounds like
yeah it sounds like she was sounding it
you guys don't know a sound esther says
sounding isn't something you see on tv
i don't think i've ever seen it on tv
honestly looks like she was sounding him
hard
like a file or something damn and
uh yeah you gotta be a tough
[ __ ] that's some hardcore [ __ ]
he might might have been a cure for um
some kind of vd
maybe maybe maybe we're like maybe our
time
gonorrhea maybe our time in the fetish
scene is like making us think that and
maybe there's like a much easier
explanation but that was just like the
could have been
where we went he was rotting him out he
might have might have had vd or
gonorrhea or the clap or something
but he was you know uh you know like
that you know if i can
deal with it but he looked like he was
kind of enjoying it too
uh and uh guys his son comes in he goes
you got some strange enjoyments that's
what he said yeah okay so maybe that was
that
okay yeah and he's like and he just
[ __ ] laughed see i didn't even see
that because that that's what woke me up
you asking me
that and i was just like i was like what
i was like i was sleeping
i was like i missed that we gotta back
that [ __ ] up i was like i was too tired
yeah but yeah uh camp guy says what if
it gets stuck
well then i guess you got to go to the
emergency room i'm sure they've seen it
on it was like a knife but i'm sure
they've seen weirder
seriously my sister used to do billing
for a gi
clinic and she used to like delight in
telling the stories of like people
getting stuff stuck up their butts
like that she had built you know what i
mean uh super super funny
and actually there's one and i think
i've mentioned this before but there's
one website or a blog or something i
can't remember what it is but
every year they do what do people get
stuck up their butts this year
like they go to some so i don't know
what site they're getting this from
but then they show like the x-rays and
everything of like people getting
various things stuck up their butts
and sometimes the excuse for how that
thing got up their butts even though
everybody knows how it got up there
yeah but some of the some of the excuses
are really creative
tina said she got four episodes in for
spartacus loving the series
the first season yeah series great
recommendation
yeah we just started the fourth one and
you had actually one season
yeah we we just started the fourth
season yeah and um
we have amazon prime but actually we
don't have the stars add-on
so we actually had to pay 10 bucks to
buy this
yeah yeah season four you got to buy it
yeah did we
did we pay for season three no they were
they were they were streaming free
maybe the season four was like so new
that they're still in charge of money
for it
yeah the other ones you um you uh just
you can watch them free with commercials
yeah but for some reason
i don't know i don't remember seeing
commercials by the time you get the
season four you got to see it anyway
well that's what they're i think that's
what they're counting on because the
first two seasons
uh we watched that's was free with
amazon prime yeah and then i can't
remember the third one but this one you
had to have the stars add-on
yeah or you had to pay 10 bucks for the
season yeah tila
by the time you get into episode four
you've already you're already
knee-deep in [ __ ] uh batiatas
[ __ ] lord batiata's the master of the
looters and [ __ ] that dude was such a
good guy yeah
and then his wife lucretia
yeah and then those two were like
honestly them two
and that uh that really treacherous
blonde [ __ ] oh yeah
she was [ __ ] great that was that pray
to his wife she was so [ __ ] evil
yeah yeah that was a glabber's wife
conte county county
oh my god such a good character yeah oh
my god she was such a
she was such an [ __ ] the acting is
[ __ ] fantastic
and that whole thing and all those dudes
are all [ __ ] test man they're either
[ __ ] on tests or on their own [ __ ]
d
ball they're all uh everybody's in
pretty good shape and then they got
[ __ ] what was his name odimayus
odimayus [ __ ] deltori yeah yeah
trainer
the african guy that's [ __ ] awesome
yeah he was an awesome character yeah
he's probably he's probably seen him by
now i think by c
by episode four you've already seen his
ass yeah when does he show up in season
one i can't remember it might be you
think it might be episode two
yeah second or third episode i'm pretty
i'm pretty sure like i said i don't even
think you find out what his name is
until later because everybody just calls
him daughter
yeah but yeah they find out you find out
what his name is like because i didn't
even know what his name was because
that's what everybody called it and
that's just like his title uh tila says
speaking of which is that richard gere
story no i don't no it's not
no i don't know why that started about
richard gere
story wasn't true either wait which one
are we talking about
right oh man this is back in the 70s
that rod stewart got rushed to the
hospital for some kind drug overdose
that pumped his [ __ ] stomach out and
it was filled with [ __ ] semen
oh yeah yeah i heard that but i don't
think it was about rod stewart i thought
it was about somebody else but i can't
remember who right now
so it's just kind of like one of those
urban legends that gets attached to
different people depending
it's pre-internet so you know what i
mean you couldn't fact check anything
that's true you couldn't you know you
didn't know the source of you didn't
know the source of the rumors either
and then somebody said it and you're
just like yeah that sounds like it
happened
yeah somebody put a hamster up there but
why not yeah look i heard the
hamstripping ass from [ __ ]
uh uh robin williams when he was playing
mork they told the same story about his
ass too
like i said that's not i mean i think
richard gere is the most popular one
but i've heard it about a couple other
actors first time i heard it was [ __ ]
it was about mork from work urban
legends are fascinating i have like a
whole [ __ ] i have i have a bunch of
books about urban legends back there uh
john brennan if you haven't like heard
of him he's like a
sociologist or like somebody or somebody
that studies that type of [ __ ]
um and he's written like a whole bunch
of books yeah uh
you know the [ __ ] what is it called
the vanishing hitchhiker the mexican pet
uh the one i have is called curses
broiled again because it's a
it has the urban legend of like people
that have gotten cooked in like tanning
beds and stuff which is also not true
um yeah as i was gonna mention esther uh
recommended to us on the patreon
uh page she sent me a message on patreon
and said that there was uh because i had
done a
review of the movie the invitation which
if you're not a patron you'll be able to
see it tomorrow it'll go public
uh and i said i really really liked uh
dinner party horror which that is
and she said oh there's another one like
that you'd probably really like called
the perfect host
yeah and uh and it's on tubey so people
are having problems uh ordering the
cookbook and show the cookbook again
jenny
yeah just in case you guys weren't here
yesterday we just got the proof
yesterday and i approved the proof today
so i'm not sure how long it'll take like
for the page to go live
it's a hardcover it looks good it's in
uh full color matte
photographs on every page we went with
matte instead of the gloss because gloss
well it's in a kitchen it'll get smeared
anyway and it would make the book about
75
yeah it would make it like twice the
price not worth it i mean and it looks
great in matt
i'm trying to like find a good page that
i haven't shared before yeah there's
fish
taco jenny said there might be problems
ordering it right now
because it might be age restricted you
might she might have to enter in an
age of what to allow people to buy it
just because it's got a lot of swearing
in it
or it could be because it just uh posted
yeah it could because of that i gotta
check later
but yeah so that's all it all kind of
looks like that
using our using our 13 o'clock colors
our little kind of
brown and aqua there but you know got a
bunch of different sections
the only thing that didn't turn out like
i thought is i wanted it to be in
english measurements or american images
i think it's english measurement
same in american measurements because
they're they're metric now
and i want it in metric but to do that
would have made each little thing
about twice the size as it would have
and it would have
i we had to redo the whole a bunch of
stuff
yeah i mean like i said i figured i kind
of i remember you saying that
like i did remember to do fahrenheit
celsius like i did remember to do that
um i think i remembered in every single
description i hope
i checked like a million dollars so the
temperatures will be messed up yeah yeah
yeah yeah
but it's like other measurements but
other than that i was kind of i remember
you saying that like after you told me
that i was just like oh [ __ ] but then
like when i was putting the book
together
i didn't and then i was just like oh
[ __ ] i forgot everything's in cups
teaspoons and
and tablespoons saundra says it has
swearing in it yeah imagine that
but you know what i mean you know how we
can't talk without wearing uh
camp guy says jenny is a genius creative
to do all that stuff well thank you very
much
on the upside um you're you're a lot of
times
uh measuring cups have both english and
metric on them
i don't know if they're like that in
other countries but in this country they
like the pyrex ones yeah
and i'm pretty much sure they sold those
whatever because sometimes
we get recipes and i'm like
what 40 millimeters how the [ __ ] is that
they're doing it in milliliters and [ __ ]
i mean they taught us the metric system
in school like when i was in school in
the
70s but and i kind of knew it at the
time but then like they didn't really
keep up with it
so i i have a rough idea but
not like uh mr roboto thank you very
much
how long till you hit the convention
circuit for the fans
we haven't been asked to a convention in
a while we went to we did a horror
convention a couple years back
um and i did a couple of panels and [ __ ]
pandemic and everything kind of put the
put all that [ __ ] to an end we've talked
about
like one of these days we maybe we
should do like a tour and do like
meetups or something instead of like a
convention
yeah i don't know it would be hard to do
that it would yeah
i don't know we'll figure it out it
would only work for locals and you know
i mean a local crowd would be small
true but if we like went on a trip
we could have a meet up at a location at
wherever we were going yeah
i mean yeah like i said i've been i
don't know i've been the kids
one of these days i'd like to go back to
st augustine
and maybe we could do like a ghost tour
and [ __ ] like that
because they got a [ __ ] on at those
doors
and you know they only like i said the
reason i did the one that i did it was
because it wasn't walking tour it was
trolling my feet retired
so i was like well i'll do this one
because it's not a [ __ ] trolley so i
don't have to like walk around um
but yeah somebody asked me uh do do do
do do
somebody ask something and i don't
know where it went to
yeah i don't know
oh that's what i wanted to say is that
you were asking me about doing
like having people on the live stream
sometimes especially like on the
wednesday shows like maybe people could
phone in
i kind of looked up how to do it um
there's several ways to do it
every single way looks like a giant pain
in the ass but
um you can't like you have to go
as far as i can determine you have to go
through like a third party you had to be
like plug-in yeah it would have to be
either zoom
or it would have to be like skype or
uh what's that one that i did the other
day stream yard uh you know i did
i did another show like with that one
and the problem with that
well particularly with stream yard is
that um
if you only have a free account yeah you
can only stream for 45 minutes at a time
yeah
and you can only have uh five or six
people
at once so you'd have to pay for it yeah
it's like a service and if you pay for
it
can you do your intros and outros
through it see i'm not sure because i'd
have to figure out
i have to figure out how because there's
so many plugins you have to figure out
how to run it through obs
like you can do it through you can do it
through here but
you you i don't know i i have to figure
out like which
probably zoom would be the best because
most people use that
yeah and i'm pretty sure you can link
obs and zoom
together like you can run zoom through
obs and then stream onto youtube
and maybe onto facebook at the same time
but i still have to like look more into
it and decide what i'm gonna do it
because if we do it through zoom
then people that want to be on the show
with us are going to have to i'm going
to have to send them a link and they're
going to have to like get in there ahead
of time so i can kind of like
get their uh get their little cameras in
there
and get everybody's like yeah so i'd
have to do like do a lot of [ __ ] ahead
of time yeah
but you know it might be something we
could do like in the future for
like i said for a sidetrack show if some
people want to be on right
uh you know they don't mind being on
video and
being on the live stream later like i
said probably i'll probably use zoom i
feel like most people use that nowadays
so i'll have to look into that like how
many people i can have how long i can
stream
[ __ ] like that because i already have
zoom on my [ __ ] because i've done some
other shows on that i have stream yard
too but like i said i think stream yard
with a free
account i don't think you can go more
than 45 minutes you know what i'm saying
like at a time
and i don't think you can have more than
six people
and even if you pay i think you can only
have up to 10.
okay so well it wouldn't be any more
than like another three or four people
yeah that's what i'm saying
wow yes discord
is also an option yeah that's true i
should probably look into that also and
i got to write that down because i was
writing down like all the different ones
and then i was thinking oh
even if you do even if you go through um
obs sometimes you can go through obs
but you'd have to download like a
third-party plug-in like a
virtual cam or ndi or something like
that so
um yeah camp guy i'm too old for more
techno now i had a
com website for my family business in
1996 and i could barely work a
smartphone now
i i feel you i feel you um well because
it just seems like
you know i'm 48 i try to keep up with
[ __ ] because i have to
you know keep up with all of this stuff
but
it's hard because like stuff changes all
the time and
we bought things we haven't even used
that yet we're like we have a video
camera right there we've never used i
know i still haven't used it
i mostly bought that because one i had
one and a little one and it broke
yes and i didn't have one that i could
carry around but two i got that one
so i could like film pookie yeah doing
cute [ __ ]
and then she could have her own channel
but i never even used it but i haven't
had time to do it yet yeah i've used it
a couple of times but not really
um you know we were gonna give pookie
our own show
or you know at least like some videos of
her doing cute [ __ ]
i mean we could give beijing her own
video but she usually is just like
she wouldn't want to do anything i
wanted to put a camera on my helmet
well yeah you were talking about that
yeah it's cheap now
yeah just not never got around to it
it's all
i mean that's the thing it's i like
having all this stuff and i like knowing
how to do all this stuff but sometimes
like i said when i was looking up
um you know how to do a live stream with
a bunch of different people on it using
obs which i already have
and it's like so i'm watching a video of
like how to do it and it's like
10 minutes in i'm my eyes start to glaze
over i'm like jesus [ __ ] christ this
looks really complicated
it's like and it's like i i i'll be able
to figure it out it's just sometimes
when i first start
like learning about it it just sounds
really daunting and i'm just like jesus
christ i don't have time to like
figure this out right now but if i set
aside
a couple of hours and figure out how to
do it i'll figure it out and do it
because i did like actually kind of
teach myself to use obs i had no idea
how to use this [ __ ] before
i'm still waiting on still waiting on
ups
yeah they should be here let me go check
oracle says it's the internet cat videos
are always in style
they are i mean how can you know like
cat videos [ __ ] i just posted on the
on the 13 o'clock facebook page today
that guy that does
uh what's his cat's name owl kitty and
he does all those movie parodies
except with his cat in them and he did
one today that was a parody of jaws
called claws
and he put he made like a trailer for
jaws but it has like a cat the cat
instead of the shark and it's like super
super funny
um that cat is [ __ ] adorable and i
like too that that sometimes
they'll have a video where they show
kind of how they do it's all like green
screen obviously
and how they get the cat to do like
different things and be in different
positions and stuff and it's just like
so so funny
did you see that i posted it on the
facebook page today what's that see what
you remember i showed you owl kitty that
little black kitty that they put in all
the movie
trailers um he just put one up today
that was of jaws
um so it's like a trailer for jaws but
instead of the shark it's
it's the cat the cat so the cat's like
coming up like really big like coming up
on the boat
like turns like eating the [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's like super funny
and all and it's funny the way they
edited together like some of the quotes
from the movie and everything like that
and changed a couple of them too my
favorite thing
was that the scene where you know quint
is sitting in front of the chalkboard
and there was like a drawing of like a
shark on there but it's like it was that
but and he was there talking but on the
chalkboard was like this big huge cat
drawing of the huge cat with like this
little tiny person like it looked like
the cat was gonna eat it
it was like so [ __ ] funny yeah uh
dota rescue channel always has cute
videos yeah i really like that uh that
channel too
that always has like really sweet stuff
on it what was the um
what was that one this morning oh this
is uh i was watching because the show
friday night
that we're going to do is about feral
children
yeah so yeah there's a whole [ __ ] out of
them so i was watching some
documentaries about it earlier russian
girl was raised as a dog
yeah yep yep i mean there's a lot to
choose from does she ever recover
some i can't remember her specifically i
don't think they recover too well i
don't think they ever even learn how to
talk it depends
yeah uh it depends what uh what age they
were when they
ran away or got lost in the forest or
whatever happened to them
depends on what age they were rescued
depends on a lot of different things
some of them never really learned to
talk
um some of them do but they're always
kind of like impaired or
there was one woman i can't remember her
name but you know we'll get more into
this on friday because
there's a whole bunch of different cases
but she was actually raised by can't
even what [ __ ] animals was she raised
by
some kind of monkeys i think and um she
actually like grew up and she kind of
went back to normal life they took her
back to her village or whatever and she
lived there for a long time but like
when she was older she was like [ __ ]
this and then she went back and lived in
the forest because she didn't like
living around people i mean and in some
ways i was like
yeah i can't kind of blame them i gotta
say it's like the monkeys were nicer to
me i'm going by
oh my god but yeah so but there was a
video that came on
after those documentaries that was about
people that were rescued by wild
animals and i thought that was like
really cool there was one case in
particular
that there was a little kid and i guess
he was only one
and um his dad he lived with his dad but
his dad was homeless
so i guess his dad was like looking for
something like in those he was looking
for like for some cardboard or something
like that
and the little kid wandered off and the
dad was freaking out because he couldn't
find him
and then later on like they found the
kid like a long time later
and it was like freezing cold wherever
it was i don't know if i don't remember
where it was but it was like really
really cold
and this kid had somehow
gotten in with a whole bunch of like
feral cats
and the cats had like protected him and
they like when he was sleeping they'd
all lay on him like to keep him warm and
[ __ ]
it was the craziest thing ever i was
like oh hero kitties well don't tell all
the stories
we'll save them for this well that one
wasn't a feral child one that was just
kind of more a kid that wanted
because he wasn't he wasn't raised by
them he just like wandered off and the
cats like kept him warm for a few days
until the people found him
it turns out that um what was that
tomorrow war
whatever that thing's doing really well
like it's getting millions
and millions of hits well yeah i saw i
saw that it had really good reviews on
amazon yeah i figured i was gonna do
good esther asks have we ever done a
show about eastern penitentiary
we haven't but you're you're not the
first person that's asked me about that
actually and i have to write that down
because
which one was that i've probably heard
of it
i'm gonna write that down i don't think
we've done
we've done so many but i'm pretty sure
we haven't done one on that
i try to like keep everything straight
but you know it's like really difficult
but um what was the other one that i was
gonna say oh cause remember when we were
watching
uh [ __ ] we were watching that uh
one of the jeremy's the jeremy wade show
yeah mysteries of the deep mysteries the
deep okay
and remember they were talking about
that one diver that that uh i think it
was a baleen whale like picked the dude
up in its mouth
oh yeah and then they were wondering
like well he well obviously he wasn't
trying to eat him because
they can't really eat anything that big
so you know um or if it was just an
accident or if he was like trying to
save him from a shark there was actually
one story on there
there was a woman and she was a marine
biologist and she was diving
and um a whale actually was acting
really weird around her like trying to
like block her and stuff and she's like
what the [ __ ] is like this whale trying
to play and it turned out that there was
a tiger shark and it was like coming at
her and like the whale was trying to
like block
the tiger shark from getting to her so
apparently that's not the first time
that that's happened
evidently whales and dolphins will do
that yeah they had a couple
of stories about dolphins as well uh and
one about a beluga whale that saved
somebody that fell into
like a tank at a thing and like dragged
her up by the
arm like to the surface because she fell
in and she couldn't get back up
whales have gone to people for help too
like they'll get caught in a net
and they'll try to get up next to a boat
and
try to get people to come get the net
off of them you seen that one
yeah yeah yeah i think you showed me
that yeah it's happened several times
they're not done nails caught in the net
i'll try to take it back to a boat
you know and just roll around in front
of the boat trying to plead with the
people to cut the net off of it
because they can't get out and then they
dude jumped in the water with a knife
you know it's huge you know he's like
well hold on hold on and he's crawling
across it trying to cut
cut the the net off of it took a long
time eventually got the net off of it
and that whale jumped out of the water
in front of the boat six seven times
yeah you showed me that video thanks man
yeah
that was awesome yeah jumping in front
of the boat
and then i saw another video too where
there was like a woman and she had a pet
uh vietnamese potbelly pig merman there
was kind of a rage for like having those
as a pet
but she had it as a pet for a while and
something bad happened to her house i
don't remember if she like fell in brook
or if she had a heart attack or
something like that
and her pig the pig's name was lulu i
remember that the pig
ran out the house went into the road and
laid down in the road
until like a car stopped and then when
the car stopped the pig was like
come on yeah and like made the person
come inside the house
and then the person like called because
because the pig couldn't call
the ambulance obviously they didn't have
she didn't have any thumbs
but you know what i mean yeah uh and you
know there was a couple with there was
one with a black bear too that
like protected a kid but you know and
gorillas do that too like because a
couple times gorilla like kids have
fallen into gorilla enclosures and like
the kids the
remember the harambe yeah they talked
about that but they were talking about
another one too that's like scooting
that kid through the water
yeah yeah i i don't think they should
have shot the gorilla though i don't
think that girl
well no that's why everybody was like
freaking out because there had been
another there had been other incidents
where kids had fallen into
guerrilla enclosures and like the
gorillas were like trying to protect
them or at least one girl was trying to
protect it from the
like a female would try to protect it
from the males i think he just didn't
know what to do with it
yeah you know he didn't know that he had
the kid
i don't think he was gonna hurt the kid
he just didn't know exactly what to do
yeah
[ __ ] man got it now what do i do
should i take it over there
yeah yeah he was just thinking about it
well you know i mean i can understand
that they were
they felt you know the zoo felt liable
and they would have been liable if the
if something had happened like i get
that but but i don't
that gorilla didn't look hostile to me
no that's what i mean and generally
i mean from what i know of gorillas
gorillas are generally
not all that hostile unless you're
really like getting up in their [ __ ]
faces
they seem like pretty chill so one video
saw one video on youtube you can find it
a chimpanzee which are much much more
dangerous than uh
yeah i'd be way more scared of
chimpanzees chimpanzee was drowning in
the moat
in the zoo and one of one of the zoo
guests jumped in the moat
grabbed that chimpanzee and took it to
the uh
to the bank and put it you know
put it up on the bank it was coughing
the other chimpanzees were looking at
him like what are you doing man that was
weird and then
back out in the water and they said
why'd you do that you know what i mean
weren't you weren't you afraid that that
chimp would would would drown you he
said
he did he said he didn't know what he
was going to do he jumped into the water
and saw it struggling and and drowning
and it turned and looked at him and he
said they made eye contact and he could
tell that it was saying help me and he
grabbed it and it
it didn't struggle and he took it
i think most animals i mean at least
most mammals and stuff seem to
understand when someone is trying to
help them yeah
they do really seem to understand
confusions can happen though well yeah i
know that and then like it does happen
when you know
i got bit by a cat who knows i was just
gonna say it's like even our cat like
she
flipped out and he was trying to like
get something off her foot that had
gotten like all tangled up and she like
flipped out and bit him on the hand
um because she was scared so it does
happen
um you know and obviously if that had
been a chimpanzee you your arms would be
gone now
he said he made eye contact with the
chimpanzee and he said there was he
that there was understanding that there
was an understanding was made oh i don't
doubt it
you know he said he couldn't describe it
he could just tell by the eye contact i
mean chimpanzees are kind of [ __ ]
but
they're not dumb [ __ ] yeah you know
what i mean they they seem to understand
well isn't there and like a lot of
monkeys too will like
save their like other monkeys if they're
hurt
like there's that one like that one
remember that one monkey that like fell
on the
like electrified tracks or whatever and
like and then they try to like they were
like he was trying
to revise to get him yeah he was doing
like [ __ ] got him back up
yeah yeah he got back up he's shaking
him he's like you're right man you're
right holy [ __ ]
we thought you were dead burn burning
hair off of him
yeah those weren't chimpanzees those
were like some other there was like some
other kind of like a capuchin type of
yeah i think it was a cabbage a baboon
type thing were they wait were they i
think it might have been baboons i
thought it was littler ones but i could
be
i could be wrong maybe somewhere in
india yeah it was india where they have
those like monkeys running around
uh saunders says i'm addicted to tiny
kittens i always like that i like that
too
they have a 24 7 365 live stream with
rescue kittens
mom cats who give birth to kittens and
you see them grow up it's adorable
yeah it is really good i like that we
were watching that korean one remember
the korean one
yeah that was all sad well a couple of
them were sad because a couple of the
stories i mean a lot of the stories
hadn't
had good endings um it was just kind of
like it's this squad i can't even
remember what it's called now but
it's kind of this squad and they get
called in like hey we found like a whole
like
bunch of kittens like trapped in a wall
or something like that
like in an abandoned building and
they'll like go and try to rescue them
um but so most of the time it's happy
but like sometimes
you know a kitten or two don't make it
and it's like i just was getting too
upset and i couldn't watch
it's like i don't know that's like
really funny to me i can i can watch
stuff where like
people die all day long but it's like if
something bad happens to a cat i'm just
like nope
and i just like turn it right off can't
even can't watch it
can't watch it and uh i was yeah i was
on facebook today and uh
my sister her uh her dog just died
and uh i mean she knew it was gonna
happen because the dog's been sick
and um she's had that dog like forever
and i was just kind of so i went on
facebook and i saw that and i was just
like oh
i can't today i just can't i can't
it's just i don't know i don't know if
in my old age i just i'm starting to
like animals more than people
but i mean i've always liked animals for
the people
generally but i'm just i can't i can't
i have a hard time like watching it in
movies even even when it's fake
like i said kill all the people yeah cut
their heads off i don't give a [ __ ]
but i was like don't even do and don't
even like look sideways
at a cat i will like freak out i'm just
turning the movie off
i'm just saying right now
[Laughter]
yeah grantham's hammer said that uh
that uh he just watched um tomorrow as
well and said about
uh was saying about uh mary lynn's powdy
face yeah
[Laughter]
and then tammy said i saw her in an
interview when 24 was on tv and someone
mentioned her resting [ __ ] face
oh mary lynn who was mentioning it no i
said who said who's mentioned it
grab their sabbath but then tammy said
that she's on interview with her
124 was on somebody mentioned her
resting [ __ ] face and she said i can't
help it that's just my face yeah
yeah there's not really a lot you can do
about resting [ __ ] face really
i don't think i don't think that i have
resting [ __ ] face i think i have
resting
i don't know i always thought i had
resting sad face because it seemed like
sometimes when i was just like
sitting staring off into space and like
not thinking about anything in
particular
i'd always have people like you know at
work or whatever and they'd be like
what's the matter
yeah i'll be like nothing's gonna matter
that's just what my face looks like i'm
sorry if my face looks like i'm [ __ ]
bummed out about [ __ ] all the time
mary lynn had she came from a
russian-american family and she has this
and everybody in her family had that
look
her dad kind of had that her mom kind of
had that look
when she was always kind of her lips and
kind of pout and her mouth was
kind of turned down like that
and then her eyes were always like hmm
and she just had that look even though
she was [ __ ] super funny
she was funny and real goofy and uh
in between telling jokes she'd go
in between it was just her mannerisms
and
and that's that's in most of them well
that's why
that's why the phrase resting [ __ ]
basically yeah i think because some
people's face just looks like that
when they're not they're not angry or
sad or anything that's just like what
they look like
but when somebody is telling jokes it's
funny because there'd be some funny [ __ ]
[Laughter]
didn't it how'd you like that
and she's [ __ ] funny yeah i love it
yeah grandpa's to tell you
i didn't realize because i never really
looked at her that closely
because i didn't watch 24. um you know i
kind of vaguely knew what she looked
like because of
because of you talking about her but you
know i so i had you had to point her out
to me in tomorrow
because i didn't remember what she
looked like yeah so when i saw that
i was kind of like oh yeah she does have
that kind of pouty
yeah she has a real pouty face when she
was younger it was even stronger
she was she was even cuter you know she
still turned out to be pretty cute but
she
was when she was you know 16 17 18 she
was even cuter
it's funny she was on the swim team too
she was real fit and she was a good
actress
well kinda kind of good
oh shade
[Laughter]
me and steve were getting all the leads
christy watson would get all the leads
because we could sing and we could dance
too
i wasn't as good a dancer back then as i
am now i could sing better now though
you are a good dancer later on i got
bigger roles when i was in brazil you
know i was i did el gaiu
in fantastics i carried the whole damn
show i had like [ __ ] six songs
and it took me a while to get [ __ ]
timing down
rhythmic timing for lyrics and [ __ ] and
you'd kind of [ __ ] freeze up
and you know it's not like today where
everybody's used to being in front of
cameras
back then you know we were doing this in
front of live audiences
and a lot of times just practicing it in
you know live was a little stressful
so you admit you did get stressed out so
it wasn't just like me
no but it went away a long time ago yeah
i lost that a long time ago
i never got over it no once once once i
did the fantastics
and did like two or three shows i didn't
know i did
did one show the first live show was
kind of stressful
and then second and third night was easy
i was having fun i was like oh i could
do this [ __ ] for years
you could do this same role over and
over again because you you got really
well oiled and real comfortable with it
grant just will tell you well you're a
lot more outgoing than me also
well you had to be that way or you would
never make it and drama
that's the way it was and that was the
that was the
um that was the uh the skill that was
that was the challenge
it was the same it's the same thing and
gramsci will tell you that's maybe
that's why i didn't have a problem with
like you know a lot of people
were oh man those jocks they're so
[ __ ] bullies they didn't bully me and
the people in the drama
too much because they saw us doing [ __ ]
live on stage
and that changes the game because see
they do live [ __ ] on the field
yeah so it's kind of like live sports
yeah
and they're like oh well they might be
in movies one day and they were right
because
mary lynn and [ __ ] everybody a lot of
other people became
youtubers or did other things in [ __ ]
you know in the art world so yeah that's
kind of where they came from that's kind
of where they come from
it starts in high school so
never had a problem with them now
another thing is is that
i think a lot i think a lot of people
according to sophie now when kids go
through high school they're they're all
the same they're like generic basic
[ __ ] they don't have
jocks and [ __ ] you know i mean punk
rockers and [ __ ] they don't have
well the clicks aren't yeah they're not
clear they're all the same they're all
just basic [ __ ]
and for us you know what i mean in our
in our generation you know
that some of those jocks had a [ __ ]
had a reputation for being bullies
yeah i knew some well the reason why
they were bullies is a lot of them were
on [ __ ]
steroids you know or they might have
just been dicks
that's steroids steroids that [ __ ] uh
is uh
makes you a dick you know and well some
people are dicks naturally though
yeah but i'm just telling you granters
knows exactly what
i'm talking about i'm just talking about
specific people some people don't need
chemical assistance the ones that were
the real dicks were
had a lot of chemical exist assistance
and by the time they were out of high
school they were [ __ ] monsters
big and they were [ __ ] crazy because
you got dudes basically
still going through puberty basically
and they're [ __ ] taking real
aggressive
steroids and they're taking them
incorrectly in an era where they weren't
really quite sure how to do it
when they had incomplete information and
incomplete medical knowledge they were
taking [ __ ] they would never take today
and if they were to take it they'd also
be on a bunch of mood stabilizers and
they'd be on [ __ ] all kinds of
things like clomid to keep keep their
systems running so they wouldn't get all
fat when they get off of it because
that's what would happen to him they get
huge
then he said dude a couple years later
and he'd be a big old fat [ __ ]
like what happened to that dude well i
don't know
you know nobody got old are you talking
about man he's 22 what do you mean he
got old
you know yeah it's because they they
didn't know about coming off cycle back
then
well we we didn't know [ __ ] about [ __ ]
back then nobody knew [ __ ] about [ __ ]
they just jacked up on synthetic in it
yeah
be jacked up on synthetic [ __ ]
improved versions of testosterone that
make you [ __ ] dick
shut your [ __ ] production down and
then when they stop taking the drug
there's no testosterone in their system
they got
[ __ ] and their balls shrivel up yeah
it is there and they just so i can get
fat
fat and weak yeah what you were saying
though about
uh oh we got somebody named gary lennon
came in i love you guys
thank you we love you too gary um
yeah what you were saying about like
high school being different nowadays see
this is something that we were thinking
about
when we were at we were at mannequins on
friday or set well it could have been
friday or saturday because we went both
nights
uh unadvisedly and we were there with
the kids
you know these these two like children
they're not children they're like 19 20.
but they're young enough to be our kids
that's why we call them kids
and we were wondering because we started
talking about
uh pretty in pink because the you know
the dj played a shell shock
by new order which is in pretty in pink
in case you didn't know
so it just reminded me of the movie and
then i was wondering to myself i wonder
does pretty and pink play the same like
if somebody that
just came out of high school or somebody
that's in high school right now if they
watch that
would it be weird to them or no i think
it would be weird i think like we talked
about this when we reviewed heather's
because the thing about heather's was
that that came out
the exact year like it was about high
school when this it came out the same
year that i was graduating high school
so it was like kind of like i mean
obviously that movie's like exaggerated
um but because nobody dressed like the
heathers at my school
that's like ridiculous but you know the
way it was done it was a black comedy
and they were doing it on purpose
but a lot of the stuff that they did in
that movie i mean
and i was just kind of wondering i was
like do people still watch like john
hughes movies
like younger kids and still get it or do
they think it's like a weird
relic that's what i wondered about i
don't know
i i when i was in high school i watched
rebel without a cause and didn't get it
i couldn't understand it and i think
that you showed a high school senior
something like
pretty in pink today they probably
wouldn't even understand it
although the thing is well the thing
about like a lot of the teen movies from
like the 50s and 60s for example
is that one those actors are not teens
and a lot of them were not even in their
20s a lot of them were in their 30s and
40s
um so that might have had some like
weird [ __ ] too but yeah that's what i'm
kind of wondering
but we talk about this a lot though
where there's i feel like there's not as
much of a difference between the
generations
as there was back then you know i mean
back then
the teenager was a fairly new concept
yeah and there was like a huge
generation gap where it's like so older
people or like the parents of
you know somebody that would relate to
the james dean character
like totally did not get like where
their kid was coming from
and i don't know if that's still the
case at least to that extent
well if you go back and watch rebel
without a cause you see james dean
being angsty and tripping over something
you don't even know what he's tripping
out about
he sees his dad's cooking at dinner his
cat dad's cooking
some kind of meal and he had an apron on
he goes daddy
oh dad he says he loses his [ __ ] over
the apron
how parrots are failing him and i
don't understand what the [ __ ] he's
talking about because his dad and an
apron on yeah he's like what's the
problem so i'm cooking
and he's oh oh yeah i don't want i don't
want grease to like splatter my clothes
oh the humanity no it's
it was some kind of uh like a gender
role thing or what is it like you're
becoming my mom or
what no i know but it's like the fact
that dad was wearing an apron did that
like you know was that some kind of like
weird i don't know how sexuality works
anymore i don't really
get how i don't know go back and watch
it doesn't mean i don't tell me what
it's about i don't get where he's coming
from
it had something to do with that
parents were not living up to their
proper
role model uh [ __ ] i guess
i didn't understand well see that's what
when you said that he was getting upset
with his dad wearing an apron
yeah i thought that must have meant oh
dad's taking over mom's role and i don't
know how
anything works anymore that's what that
was my perception
but i don't know if that's true or not
girl back then i didn't grow up you're
asking the wrong person well i'm not
asking you i'm just like speculating
yeah i just
i can't answer it because i i did not i
did not i did not
wasn't raised in that culture or that
time so i didn't have the cultural yeah
i can't i could didn't understand it
yeah because the dad was like what were
you talking about i'm just cooking
oh my god it's where she is what
everybody would say nowadays what the
[ __ ] are you
getting upset about i'm wearing an apron
parrots are failing they're not like
they were back in the days you know i
mean
i gotta watch now i see i saw it but it
was a long time ago i don't know yeah
there's a bunch of
cultural things that i couldn't [ __ ]
i couldn't i couldn't figure it out
and then uh he was unhappy about
something but you really can't tell you
really have no idea what the [ __ ] he's
complaining about
he's in an upper middle class family
well he's a rebel without a cause
yeah so he doesn't have anything to
whine about him
there's a younger dude younger dude and
some chick and then he's
he's daredeviling around in these cars
and i think he gets killed he gets
he gets killed at the end of it he runs
the car earlier runs the car off a cliff
and then his death is kind of
meaningless but you're supposed to take
some kind of
lesson from it man i need to rewatch
that i didn't really
understand what the message was i
haven't seen it since i was a teenager i
didn't know what the message was
teen angst yeah i guess it's just
general teenage
you don't understand me yeah it's like
that i mean i get that
like all teenagers have that forever
there's no point
to the movie i didn't see any point well
they were just trying i guess they were
just trying to convey like i said
generalized
teen angst like and you know yeah like
that's why it's called red pulled out
cause
he didn't have any reason i don't know
being that way maybe everybody's being
that way maybe maybe i'm thinking about
it
maybe you guys have seen the movie right
recently yeah what else is i haven't
seen it recently
as a teenager i didn't comprehend it i
was like
older people were telling me how cool
that movie was that was like a movie of
their
generation you know what i mean yeah how
cool that movie was that that movie was
like the movie
but that movie was meaningful to us kind
of like pretty and pink would be to you
right
i saw the [ __ ] and i was like this movie
is [ __ ] garbage i don't get it like
this
this movie tila said i remember that
movie uh with james dean he thought his
father was too soft oh so i was right
about that uh because he was wearing an
apron
and his mom ran over the dad okay okay
so it was all like oh
the gender roles are reversed and i
can't handle it which is like that's
hilarious hilarious but anyway what was
funny is that
i didn't even notice that lesson it just
seemed like a normal
no well that but that was the first
thing i thought of when you though
because i cast my mind back to 50s
yeah because i've seen all those like
terrible like educational films like
from the 50s and very much like it's a
very woman
thing like to wear an apron and like run
around your house and pearls and like
doing all this [ __ ] with your kitchen
and whatnot so the first thing when you
said that he got mad about him wearing
apron i said oh because he thinks he's
like turning into a woman
yeah i guess but that's what he was
upset about
yeah but that's only because you know
i've seen a lot of this he's looking at
that from a 50s
50s yeah that's what i said that's why i
look back i didn't see that at all
as a teenager i didn't know what he was
talking about well yeah you wouldn't
nowadays because that's like no one
would care
right like so it's not really something
that yeah the dad didn't care he's like
i'm cooking
i only thought about it because like i
said i've seen all those 50s
like yeah like his terrible like 50s
educational film
yeah he was just cooking something so i
knew that he was getting what he was
getting at i will say a relationship
between the man
and between the the the mother and the
father i didn't
see anything unusual about it yeah i
don't think there was anything unusual
about it
just like they were just normal people
james dean was just crying
i think the people that wrote it were
just had weird weird definitions of
way things were supposed to be well and
scott points out too
and this is what i was maybe trying to
convey before and i didn't get really
get across but teen x was a new idea
in media then yeah so that's i think
that's why the movie is iconic more than
anything because
that's really like the first time that
that had been portrayed
and like i said i think that people
they didn't realize that there was this
generation that was growing up that
didn't really
like they felt like they didn't know
their place in the world and that was
kind of like the first time that that
had ever been conveyed in a movie yeah
you know what i mean there was another
good marlin brandon movie called the
wild one
these motorcycle racers now that one i
like i like that one that was a little
bit better
we saw that one not too long ago a
little bit better the thing was is that
they weren't that wild they were well
regular [ __ ]
no they were just doing the regular [ __ ]
that [ __ ] dudes do
you know what i mean well that's what
you said that's what cracked me up about
like a lot of those 50s movies it's like
people are just doing like normal [ __ ]
and everybody's like acting like it was
this big huge deal
yeah they're in the bar drinking and
joking oh my god they're just
such miscreants yeah i won the race
here's my trophy you know
and then he's chasing a girl around and
this girl's [ __ ] loving on this dude
you know what i mean and
that's gonna happen and then but he
isn't you know what's funny is that
brando [ __ ] from what i remember i
haven't seen a long time
he was looking good but he didn't even
know how to [ __ ] really act around
women
i guess maybe they guess maybe dudes
really didn't know how to [ __ ]
they didn't know how to date we're an
alien species man
haven't you heard your date it was like
i was like just [ __ ] knock the [ __ ]
down man [ __ ] kiss her
you don't have to talk about anything
stop being so weird yeah just put on the
back of the bike just be regular
yeah take her out to the graveyard man
take her out to the graveyard sticker
stick her up on top of their [ __ ]
cribs do some return on the living dead
yeah i'm all right i'm down with that uh
but she was up for it
i could tell she was up for it back
because he didn't
he didn't know what to do he didn't know
what to do
yeah you know what i mean it's all tough
but he doesn't have to let it lay down
well like i said i think that pipe down
i'm getting the point where i'm almost
going to put a wig on you might have to
put away
make it a good let me get uh get you
that drink over there all right good
beat next man no you're not knock it off
you're not sleepy uh yeah bring a
blanket unless you like cold marble oh
yeah
that's a good pro tip for anybody
wanting to do that in a cemetery
uh beatniks man yeah um
what man what's that movie that was on
mystery science theater it might have
just been called the beatniks no it was
called the rebel set
actually it's called the rebel set and
it was about
some beatniks well movie beatniks
and they get involved in this [ __ ]
heist is it train heist
something like that but there's like a
beet coffee house in there
and that was like a [ __ ] hilarious
movie what i was gonna say is that one
of my favorite 50s movies
was the one with god damn it mimi
vandoren
girlstown yeah it was called girlstown
and uh she
is some kind of like miscreant criminal
not really um she just kind of has like
a date with a guy and apparently that's
a big deal and uh she doesn't have
uh parents so i guess she like lives
with her aunt or
some crazy woman and so and she's poor
so they kind of like give her a lot of
[ __ ]
and uh my favorite thing about that
movie
is that is the slang that she uses and
i'm not sure
if any of this slang was actually in
common
use at the time that this movie came out
or if they just made some [ __ ] up or if
it was just some kind of
because i feel like a lot of times these
movies are uh girls down
i feel like a lot of times these movies
are kind of written by
people that um either just heard the
phrases once or really don't know how
slang works or something like that and
they just want to make it sound like hip
and cool
so they kind of go overboard with it
kind of like that movie last american
virgin
yeah it's that kind of thing i'm like
but nobody talks like that just please
stop
but it's like i don't know and for some
reason like girls town it was like kind
of charming
because she just went so overboard with
the slang and it's just like i watched
it on mst
and uh at one point crows just like stop
slanging what are you saying
and it's like that's what i mean it's
like nobody could understand like what
there was like all the [ __ ] slang
term shoes i was like nobody uses that
much slack come on
there was this movie that with these
they used to play it on cable
it was a teenager when i saw it it was
called the last american virgin
i remember that's a classic made by
cannon wasn't it no
oh was it oh it might have been it's a
classic today man but when it came i saw
a cable a million times when it first
came out when
it was always on people were like what
the [ __ ] and
it's a movie about a bunch of teenagers
but
i guess they're teenagers far away and
you know the universe or something you
don't
know any teenagers that are exactly like
this
and all kinds of stereotypical [ __ ]
happens through the whole [ __ ] movie
they even show a girl getting pregnant
and getting abortion
just they're all there
which actually fast times at ridgemont
high was a lot more
true to life yeah that was more like
normal
people i think fast times came out and
then this was a ripoff
a ripoff of it yeah and here's the thing
is that the movie was written by
two israeli jewish dudes that had just
moved into hollywood and they're in
their 50s and
they don't know anything about being a
teenager they made all that [ __ ] up
and [ __ ] i saw i saw some
interviews on it some people that were
in it they were like they were reading
the script and like what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ]
like this yeah everybody these dudes
wrote it and they just wrote it based on
just stereotypes
and other movies and other movies and
just they
they just totally pulled that thing out
of their ass it just was there was
nothing
i feel like there was a lot of kind of
gang movies like that like in the 80s
too where it's just like
and they all had like the same outfits
like uniforms and stuff like what gangs
have you guys hung out with nobody does
that
come on that's like some [ __ ] you see
off a [ __ ] you know
it like that's like something you'd see
like one of those dance troops
yeah right no gang would be caught dead
in that [ __ ] of course not
like [ __ ] [ __ ] man if you're in some
hardhat gang [ __ ] man we can't even wear
the same shirt on the show and we're not
even in the hard-ass gang
remember that [ __ ] movie the warriors
yeah well that's what i was thinking
yeah people would [ __ ]
remember people thinking when we were in
[ __ ] we were like in third fourth
grade
people talking about oh man how [ __ ]
how that movie was hard
you see that [ __ ] now man that's just
i'm like they all [ __ ] uniforms
what's that they all yeah they're all
wearing uniforms that nobody's got any
guns
we're all gonna should we all to
coordinate our yeah
dance moves and [ __ ] it's like a michael
jackson video yeah that's just like a
michael jackson video
and you're like this is a game yeah that
[ __ ] would not fly today man
uh no you should get your ass beat in
five seconds you get shot
up yeah ms-13 to get you and [ __ ]
chop you up with a machete all right
david says tom already has a wig on
jesus yeah i know yeah yeah it's it's
it's going we're only in hours
they the old concept of what a gang was
just you know i mean
well you don't they don't actually kill
anybody you know that's that
what are you talking about sure they do
but in the movies in the movies no they
don't kill anybody they don't even have
guns
we just have rumbles yeah and uh you
know drag races
yeah yeah they're just good kids they're
just bad guys and dance-offs
yeah well they had rumbles in west side
story they were kind of fighting with
knives and stuff that well no they got
killed in west side story
right yeah but so they were kind of hard
so they were hard more hardcore than the
warriors although i haven't seen the
warriors yeah the warriors they had bats
and [ __ ] like that but nobody ever just
popped out with a [ __ ] shotgun and
started blowing people away
true now i will make an exception for
the drugs and clockwork orange because
they had coordinated outfits but they
were also
terrible sociopaths they were also
raping people and raped and killed
many people so you know that's it's not
a killer
person uh yeah well by accident well
they beat the [ __ ] out of lots of people
and they didn't care if they died
yeah and that that woman just died like
accidentally
it was a different environment though it
was you know what i mean it was a cop
that was kind of communist and they
didn't have any guns
i don't even think the cops had guns
yeah i can't remember yeah yeah yeah
yeah you have guns
yeah they just like they like this
version of britain
they like to beat the [ __ ] out of each
other's
yeah tila says warriors how the hell are
you going to fight wearing roller skates
yeah see that's what i always wanted
[ __ ] was it was lame [ __ ] gangs yeah
but like i said you didn't really i mean
the kids that were
watching these movies in the early 80s
they grew up in the [ __ ] suburbs man
i mean you know they watch like steven
spielberg movies and why not
so it's like you'd see one of those and
you thought it was like real illicit
because that was like ooh that's like
real tough like the first the first
movie that i saw
that [ __ ] had like gangs in it and
that i thought was realistic and
and and was kind would seemed to be
pretty [ __ ] tough
was escape from new york yeah yeah
david june asked wasn't there a mime
gang in warriors
i think there was it was just i get it
confused with fame though i have to say
really you go back and you go back and
look at it and they look like [ __ ]
like gay dance troops every one of those
gangs
danny rowland ghostface says those gangs
were about as scary as meatloaf
pretending to be a biker in rocky horror
pictures yeah yeah
yeah uh thank you liam c
england through to the euros soccer
final on sunday come on okay
we'll head on with your sports ball
[Laughter]
sports ball sports ball one thing i
wanted to say about pretty in pink
before we got off that like i said now
i'm kind of interested because
i told the kids you guys should watch
pretty in pink and then get back to me
and give me a report because i'm kind of
like curious as to what you can think
so we're like what you think about it
and we were talking about it and then i
was like one
annie potts character in that he was
like the older chick that
like ran the punk rock record store was
uh
bad ass i loved her [ __ ] spiky ass
she's the cutest girl in the movie
one of my favorite lines of that movie
was when she was talking to her
ex-boyfriend on the phone and she says
since when
since i spent the night tied up in the
backseat of your car
like she hangs up on him uh and then
when she turned into a yuppie at the end
it made me look super super sad
so that and also molly ringwald
[ __ ] up a perfectly good 50s retro
gorgeous prom dress to make what is
possibly the ugliest prom dress in all
movie history what the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] polka dotted bag she was wearing
holy crap that wasn't even in style in
the 80s i know she was all trying to be
like unique and everything but jesus
christ woman
and all the [ __ ] she was wearing before
that was actually pretty decent like
impassable i was like i lit
little hats and like kind of the boho
kind of [ __ ] she was wearing it was cool
then she makes that then she cut up that
like really cool dress
that annie potts character gave her and
like makes it into like essentially a
shapeless bag
and i was just like [ __ ] i don't like
you anymore
also she should have ended up with ducky
no t yeah t
t points out that one of those gangs was
baseball players i remember that [ __ ]
that's right i forgot about that yeah oh
my god sometimes i've seen that [ __ ]
yeah i'd be real intimidated if i saw
that and then the dude talking him with
the [ __ ] bottles on his fingers that
was uh what's the old little what's his
name you go
come out to play who's that about a play
yeah who's who's that dude
he was uh he ended up being a big star
for a while oh my god we should do a
movie retrospective
jump why are you trying to get in the
closet there's nothing in there
yeah you've been in there you were in
there earlier and there was nothing in
there she thinks there's something
different in there every time
she thinks if she goes out that door
it's another outside no
that is that's the closet there's
nothing in there pokey except like
foam she's going i gotta get in and wigs
yeah the baseball first warrior
yeah see esther agrees the prom dress
was terrible the warriors
even back then it was terrible i don't
really understand like why she didn't
just wear it the way it was it was like
nice the way it was
it would have been totally cool because
it was like yeah it was like retro 60s
and stuff but that's totally awesome
i don't know i don't know why she had to
cut it up and make it like look i'm
wearing a bag
look she's begging oh pokey she turned
around she's like me
okay come here can i go in the closet
don't mess up the lighting too much
no not that one well like well but open
this one though
now oh there you go yeah she's like with
that she doesn't know where it opens
she's not the same
[Laughter]
it's a sliding door and she thinks it'll
open in the middle she's
clawing at the middle yeah she keeps
going and they go no i gotta go to this
one
she's like oh okay oh that's right oh
now you're
now you're done already yeah she's like
that wasn't exciting because i thought
it was i think she's more
she's more entranced with the idea of
what might be in there
and then when she's actually in there
it's kind of like disappointing
you know it's just kind of like life in
general
but she just understands that hmm
okay talk loud guys i gotta go peel some
shrimp
victor just arrived hey y'all hi there
yeah camp guy says molly ringwald was in
the first draft short of slingblade with
billy bob
yeah i heard about that she didn't she
like moved to france later
i felt like she moved to france and then
like she was in a bunch of french movies
i thought we just we just saw her
not too long ago she was in one of the
creep show episodes like from the
the shutter series but um
she was in yeah i mean i still love
pretty in pink
and uh what was the other one that was
like a gender swap version of that
uh what the [ __ ] was the name of that
movie the one with uh
eric stoltz in it some kind of wonderful
that was also quite good
because because that girl that was in it
that played watts that blue is the
drummer she was like super
she was super rad i liked her yeah the
dude with the bottles on his fingers man
who was that you guys knew who that is
drop his name in the damn comment
section he ended up being a um
a famous actor he was big in the 90s
[ __ ] i can't remember now i haven't seen
that movie he was an activist too
in a long time he was like on par bono
and [ __ ]
you know like yeah yeah i call him bono
not like sunny but
boner but he was uh
[Laughter]
[ __ ] um he was a he was a damn
activist and [ __ ]
for a long time trying to remember that
motherfucker's name
and then he just vanished like what
happened that guy
well you know you could look it up on
google yeah i have to get out of stream
if i do that oh okay
you know who he is oh i'm sure i do i
just can't think of it i haven't seen
the warriors in like forever
he was in 48 hours with eddie murphy
wait who's in 48 hours nick nolte no
uh [ __ ]
i can't remember either okay it's coming
i'm looking through the
damn this is a [ __ ] huge cast
what the warriors yeah well yeah there
was like a million people in that movie
there were so many gangs
in all their silly outfits
[Music]
and we've seen passing it i must be
missing his name
um as soon as i see it i'd recognize it
yeah i can't see that it's too small
i can't see that
uh
i can't really see it
let you worry about it then you worry
about it your hair is just
it's killing me yeah it's it's doing its
job
[Laughter]
oh dj everybody's giving you hints
he was in vfw david patrick kelly
was that who you were thinking of no i
think he passed over it
yeah grampur's hammer says the gangs i
worked with okay yeah
i thought it was somebody else yeah okay
the gangs i worked with in detroit never
wore face paint just saying
yeah it seems like um seems like a lot
of trouble you know
to just go out and do go out and do gang
[ __ ] like i said to coordinate outfits
and
let's all make sure we're wearing the
same thing team spirit you know
yeah yeah i thought it was uh i thought
it was somebody else
um i think the dude i was thinking about
was actually in uh one
one of the uh one of the death wishes
maybe maybe that's why i didn't know
what you were talking about because you
were talking about a completely
different person yeah i was talking
about a completely different person
okay well that's they looked similar
from what i remember okay
be laughing i was laughing at fourth
door towns comment high octane thrills
as a group of people go home on the
train
[Laughter]
i don't know man i do laugh though
because it really does seem like
in the 80s a lot of the villains
in 80s movies were punk rockers or
looked like punk rockers well you could
pick on them without having to [ __ ]
uh be become racist that's what it is i
guess
you just get a white person he says well
we can't have elmer stan
in here we need an urban white person oh
a punk rocker
they weren't urban anyway to begin well
and new york and the thing about it too
is that they're like oh well they look
weird and everybody will believe
that exactly you know what i'm saying
you're not gonna they'll be [ __ ]
even though
every like 99 of all punk rockers and
gods i knew were like lovely lovely
people and they were they were suburban
kids
yeah usually yeah
none of them were in gangs that i know
of no never knew any goth gangs
man granters [ __ ] dated all the
[ __ ] punk rock girls from [ __ ]
tran that's right they're they're like
punk rockers and gots tended to be like
very nice that's why i always used to
laugh when i used to see that in the 80s
like that they always made them like
gang members and movies i'm like i have
never seen that in real life
and the punk rock guys were popular they
were popular as punk rock girls remember
oh man [ __ ]
um grampus remembers bill i think his
name was uh
bill um winger there's his name bill
wenger remember him
i might have the name wrong and then
they had the uh
the kid with the uh black mohawk and the
[ __ ] leather jacket and the [ __ ]
combat boots and [ __ ]
i forgot that dude's name he was a trip
too he's like a little billy idol dude
he's always had a [ __ ] angry look on
his face
dudes were [ __ ] with him all the time
but like the pug rock girls loved that
dude
jason badass asks the heck is tom
wearing that's his
worry about it that's his michael caine
in the hand wig don't worry about this
[ __ ]
also a willy wonka wig [ __ ] are
trying to analyze don't analyze just go
with it
this is the problem with with life is
that people see things and they start
asking questions
they start asking questions they try to
analyze and put it into a box
don't do that okay just [ __ ] roll
with it just be zen
just [ __ ] yeah be in the moment this
is zen true zen
true zen and enlightenment is
recognizing
the power and allowing things to remain
[ __ ] up
like you see something you could change
it but then you go
no no i'm just gonna let it i'm too lazy
i'm just going to let it remain [ __ ]
up well it depends on what it is some
things you don't want
to remain [ __ ] up like i said when our
when our uh bathroom was flooding
you don't want to leave that [ __ ] up
uh because that'd be bad
uh esther says punk rockers was the
easiest to pick on yep
they were bullied when i was in high
school yeah me too yep
so yeah those were and i knew a kid in
high school
and he was seriously he was the
loveliest he was just a lovely lovely
person
i'm sure he probably still is wherever
he is now
um but he had big robert smith hair he
wore eyeliner
uh he's gay but he didn't come out until
later so we didn't know that at the time
uh because he was still kind of trying
to date girls and stuff
um but man he got his ass kicked all the
time and it was really sad because he
was like the sweetest dude ever yeah
grandpa's name
bill olinger that's right man bill was
bill was the man
he was the [ __ ] man i don't know if
you know anything about that
but he was running game
with all kinds of [ __ ] punk rock
girls
not only from trenton but also from
[ __ ] woodhaven and everything
and bill was cool bill was [ __ ] fun
he's fun to hang out with
and i want to say running game but
that's just that's not really what it
was
he just was like a a tall
good looking punk rock dude that knew
how to [ __ ] do the punk rock look
right
and [ __ ] all the punk rock girls from
all the [ __ ] surrounding
neighborhoods
[ __ ] had shrines built to [ __ ]
bill olinger
yeah i remember him and then the other
one you said the one we're talking about
was james christie that sounds about
right i think he's i think his name
was james i think i just knew him as
james
james was the mini version of that he
got picked on a lot though james
he had that [ __ ] mohawk but
but those punk rock girls liked him he's
funny i like he sat next to me in
one of my classes and [ __ ] i wasn't a
punk rocker at the time actually i was
[ __ ] like heavy metal
at that time still and i was like what's
up man he's my [ __ ] off
the first time i said that's the first
time i met him because man [ __ ] off
well i have to say that
it got better later but in the 80s
uh punk rockers and gots and heavy metal
people really did not hang out together
yeah no no
i hung out with a couple heavy metal
chicks in high school
yeah um but they did not get my thing
and i did not get their thing but we
hung out like together
you know i think james realized i wasn't
taking a piss out of him
yeah i mean normally
i don't know is it my group was kind of
like diverse in the sense that we had
some punk rock we had some sky people we
had like
some [ __ ] goth people and like
everyone that was just kind of like
weirdos kind of hung out together
but even then like the heavy metal
people it wasn't like it didn't really
overlap
all that much like a little bit we
weren't hostile to one another but it
didn't really overlap all that much
said he's a high school english teacher
now i don't know if he's talking about
bill or james
uh and victor brings up [ __ ] good
thing if victor brings up a [ __ ] big
problem that
a lot of gay dudes have he says i hate
it when dudes think i'm gay when i'm
having sex with them
it's that annoying dad that's so
annoying i understand that
i get it let's jump into conclusions huh
yeah well you know
it's all on the spectrum just don't
don't assume things
mr roboto says why no goth gangs
honestly the only goth gang i've ever
heard of was from that [ __ ]
uh that was a cramp song sheena's in a
gaff gang or was it a roman song i can't
remember now
when i was in high school there were no
goth gangs goth didn't really exist
until
it didn't exist as a codified thing
until i was already a senior
and it really wasn't and that's that
wasn't a high school thing at my age in
my generation that was a club thing
you had to be older yeah i mean that's
the thing it's like when i was in
you trickled down when i was in junior
high in
the mid-80s um
we had like the new waver people which
were kind of like the proto-goth people
you had that going on um and we all kind
of hung out together you had the heavy
metal
people who hated us um and then
you had like just the regular ass like
jackson cheerleaders who beat our asses
all the time
or made fun of us high school like i
said it was a little bit different
because
everybody that was kind of like i grew
up in daytona which is a little bit
rednecky but the school i went to was a
little bit nicer
i didn't go to like a real trashy one so
we had some people that were into uh you
know like
you know i knew some people that were
really into like hardcore like throbbing
gristle and pale head and [ __ ] like that
you had some people that were in the sky
you had people that were like old-school
punk rock you had that kind of [ __ ]
and then you had like the goth people
that were into like cocktail twins and
all that kind of [ __ ]
and we all kind of hung out together
just because we got picked on a lot
so there was a bunch of us that all like
come kind of hung out together thank you
victor
for the hurricane kit fund i think that
that's probably going to pass us
it hit uh the panhandle yeah that's far
from here
i mean this morning though like last
night i woke up at like five in the
morning because i'd go to the bathroom
and like it was [ __ ]
pissing down rain holy crap it was like
so loud but we didn't have a lot of
storms
and even this morning i couldn't even go
for my walk because it was like pouring
down rain
like at the time that i usually go so
but we're kind of used to it but that i
mean it hit
where uh elsa made landfall is up by
like that was like up by the panhandle
which is several several miles from us
so we'll be all right we just get like
the edge of it you all right
yeah you sure yeah
i should not be all right i don't know
you're looking at me like you have that
weird look
i'm just drunk oh okay fourth throw down
says we had a goth girl gang at my
school
ooh sexy i want to get involved with
that they were scary but i got to know
them and they were lovely
that's what i mean i kind of feel like
and maybe this is why
this always happened in movies in the
80s
because you know they looked like
weirdos
it was very easy to other them and make
them like all scary and [ __ ] but
honestly if you talk to most of them
most of them are just like 99
of them are just like lovely lovely
people very intelligent
uh very knowledgeable very like
empathetic just beautiful people i
really only have met
and being in the goth and punk scene
like for a long time and i hung out with
a lot of punks too like back in the day
because my brother was in a punk band
and i used to hang at all those clubs
and stuff
99 of those people awesome
just awesome people just really nice
normal people
everyone's scared of them because they
look weird but most of them are nicer
than most normal looking people that i
meet so
just saying that's why i have kind of a
distrust
of people that look sort of normal
because i don't know what they're hiding
you know what i mean if you look like a
weirdo all the time i kind of figure
like all your weirdness is right there
and it's on the surface and you're not
like ashamed of it and you're like going
out in your everyday life looking like
that
so right there there's like a level of
honesty
and you know so that's something that
means a lot to me
normal looking people i don't know how
to approach that you might be a serial
killer i don't know
she's exaggerating no i'm just saying no
i'm just saying have you ever seen a
serial killer
that looked like a goth no no that yeah
have you ever seen a terrorist that
looked like a goth no okay
nope normal looking people can blend in
this is why i don't trust them because
you're not wearing your weirdness on the
outside
so the weirdness is all inside and i
don't know what that weirdness is
might be harmless but might not be you
know
[Laughter]
might not be victor says we had a
latina girl gang in junior high they
were just larping but they just have
fist fights at school every now and then
sandra says when a real hurricane comes
do you nail your window shut and stuff
like in the movies
i don't think we ever did that some
people do like some people have
if you have money you can get hurricane
shutters
and some people will put you know they
have like these really hard core like
shutters and they put them on like as
soon as hurricane season starts which is
june
1st yeah june 1st so they'll put it up
just in case
most people don't do that though i don't
see it a lot
um what a lot of people will do
especially kind of
you know if you don't have the money for
hurricane shutters because they are kind
of pricey
but when you hear hurricanes coming some
people will put like plywood and [ __ ]
over their windows some people just put
tape on there but that doesn't do [ __ ]
so don't bother
that's the era we're talking about
that's what it looked like that kid in
the background looks like robert smith
except
yeah younger and cuter
[Laughter]
fourth throwdown said you realize that
most normal people at school are
actually crazy oh yeah i totally
realized that
everyone's crazy in their own way it's
just kind of like
then there was this action remember that
everyone's faces are white i can't see
that [ __ ] yeah you can't see it yeah
yeah that's like a very new wavy
type of thing tammy says i'm gonna
become gotham then a serial killing
terrorist
just you'd be the first one i've just
never seen that well because
here's the thing that i tell like that
we've talked about before i said have
you ever seen you say
rob a bank with a huge like green mohawk
no why would you because everyone would
[ __ ] remember that wouldn't they
check him out see that's a darling
i love that that would have been about
88 right
somewhere around there yeah 89. see i
love that right
that's exactly the type of dude that i
would have like fallen in love with
in the 80s dude there was a guy that
used to work
he didn't go to school with me because i
think he was a couple years older
there's another one that the girls would
have liked hold on
i mean look at that hair that's
fantastic
that needs to come back can't focus
yeah everybody looks like they don't
have a nose yeah but there was a
there was a guy i was in high school he
was probably like a few years older he
didn't go to my school
he worked at the mall at mr dunderbox
which is like the german restaurant and
he was like oh man he had like the big
hair just like that
and he was like all like skinny and
knobby and pale and stuff oh my god he
was like [ __ ] fantastic
i love that backwards in time i can't
remember what that dude's name was but
he was like he was super super [ __ ]
hot
can't get the face
granters i know you're in there bro i'm
gonna take you back hold on and my
cousin knew him
and so i was kind of like trying to tell
her it's like hey put in a good word for
me so like i can go by there and like
you know what i mean but i was a lot
younger so
but he was like super cute
yeah see i'm i mean i like the big hair
i like the big hair
granters remember her yeah you showed
that before yeah i don't think i showed
panthers
saunder makes a good point she says you
know what all serial killers have in
common
they aren't funny and they can't laugh
about themselves
yeah they're not they're not fully
developed people
yeah because there is something in
and you know what i think she's kind of
hit upon something profound there
there is something about a person that
is not
introspective enough um
to be able to realize when they're being
absurd or when they're like being [ __ ]
up or whatever like it's
almost like they don't have that
capacity to like look in at themselves
and be like oh my god i'm being
ridiculous right now
maybe that's what it is maybe they don't
have that facility
to like be able to laugh at themselves
because people that can't laugh at
themselves are like the worst [ __ ]
people
you know i i kind of feel like that's
sort of a big
thing that you have to have like to be
a normal person or at least a person
that you want to hang out with
okay no granters that was gene man gene
patrowski remember her
all right i gotta pee so
take the calm yeah
i was gene pokatrowski sitting in a
parking lot
trent high all [ __ ] punk rocked out
hmm
hold on let me see what this going on
you were close not genie but jean yeah
jean's still in michigan
she married got married a guy
i'm drinking um pinnacle whipped cream
vodka excuse me
pinnacle coconut vodka and pineapple
juice
it's good kind of like a stronger
version of malibu
i can't believe it's almost 6 30.
see grandpa said something i can't read
it let me see
no she's no she's just like a normal
she's just like a normal mom
let me go check this out okay oh yeah he
had like a package coming
wait who's a normal mom what did i lose
jason batta says what you drinking tom
oh my god i don't know
i could have told you but i don't i
don't know
what about gacy he was clowning yeah but
clowns are creepy though even back
even back in the day before anybody knew
that oh about john wayne gacy clowns
were still creepy
so i don't think that dressing as a
clown is
and he i don't think he dressed as a
clown while he was doing the serial
killing right i mean you know
jason badass asked what you were
drinking i told him
oh okay
the thunder's happening bad out there i
know i heard it when i was coming back
in here
brain's gonna start coming down what
else is new
i mean it's pretty much yeah it's
tropical is i
i don't know if it went to hurricane or
if it's still a tropical storm i haven't
checked for like several hours
because i checked earlier and i was like
oh it's hitting the panhandle it's like
ah [ __ ] it
we'll just get the edge it'll be fine
but
summer in florida in case you didn't
know pretty much every afternoon
you get really bad thunderstorms that's
when i get like upset about tropical
storms and stuff because i'm like
happens kind of every day
um you know
[Laughter]
yeah what uh you said somebody had gone
like normal
gone normal
gene just you know um
got married and had kids and just became
like
somebody's mom you know that's how it
goes
going to the football games with the
husband and [ __ ]
that always kind of depresses me i don't
know why yeah
she was cute because like she was in
high school and she had a [ __ ] tattoo
a lot of people didn't know that she had
a [ __ ] black widow tattoo
[ __ ] tattooed on her [ __ ] shoulder
which was kind of a big thing
big deal back then yeah i mean [ __ ] when
i got my first tattoo which is
since been covered up yeah the tattoo
artist didn't want to do it on my arm
because he thought everyone would think
i was a hoe
yeah he's like can i do it where
somewhere i can cover it up like on like
your lower leg
it was and it was a good 80s tattoo you
know what i mean it wasn't
you know i think it was done at home but
i think it was it was done at home by a
tattoo artist she must been dating a
tattoo artist
yeah somebody had a machine at least or
dating somebody who
was friends with a tattoo artist she had
a damn um
black widow spider tattooed on her back
shoulder
look cool though yeah i saw that [ __ ]
she was like 17.
i was like wow you know that's [ __ ]
awesome
she kept that [ __ ] covered up school i
don't even think her parents knew she
had that
well yeah like i said back then you
really had to kind of
it's funny now because everybody has
tattoos and there's like no stigma about
it at all
no it was about the size of a silver
dollar but back in the 80s
it's like they yeah and even like i said
the tattoo artist he was like an old
biker that did my first tattoo like i
said it's been covered up now
but he it was an owl but it i didn't
cover it up because it was shitty i just
covered it because it was
like starting to bleed away and it
wasn't looking as cool as it uh did to
white i covered up with something better
but yeah like the old biker told me i
think it was in the late 80s
early 90s i guess i can't remember when
i got that done it was like a long time
ago
but he said that he's like yeah people
think he said to me and i remember this
quote very specific he's
since died uh r.i.p because he was a
nice dude
but he said people think things about
girls that have tattoos on their arms
that's what you told me this was like 91
maybe
yeah something like that it was back in
the day yeah
so there was still like a stigma about
the time 96 97 was rolling around that
was kind of shaken loose though
yeah i kind of feel like because i
remember like back in the old days like
people wouldn't even like pleat they're
like don't dye your hair weird colors
don't shave your head weird
because i shaved my head weird in high
school and
my parents didn't care but like other
people were like you're never going to
be able to get a job with hair like that
that's what it was back then and back
then you wouldn't be able to because our
grandparents were still in charge
yeah if you had like tattoos or you had
like weird colored hair or anything like
that
it's time to put a smoked cigarette you
got a lighter over there no i think you
left them uh
yeah you left them in the somebody was
asking if um
if we liked [ __ ] scotch whiskey i
like
i like whiskey yeah i'm not a i'm not a
big
i like single malt scotch whiskies those
are good i like glenfiddich
if you want to send me a bottle of
glenfiddich go ahead and contact james
that was shameless he doesn't care
i like whiskey on occasion i didn't
drink it for a long time because
i kind of feel like i used to drink it a
lot and i felt like when i got
drunk on whiskey i got like super
aggressive
um which tom was not a fan of like i'd
get really angry
um but enough time has passed
that now i can drink a few and kind of
get drunk on it and not
and just be like drunk and happy or
whatever so i don't
but normally i usually just drink vodka
i mean vodka is kind of my
liquor of choice i guess but i like
other [ __ ] too i like gin as well
but i can't drink that many of those
because it's too acidic
so but whiskey's good you know
okay yeah i'm gonna change my hair uh-oh
santa said jenny's hair looks great
thank you thank you tom just cut it last
night
yeah i wanted to go back to like i said
i used to have it all shaved under here
and it
took several years to grow back out but
i was kind of going back to we're do so
we're doing the mohawk it
i didn't have it like put it completely
up because i'd have to
i'd have to uh tease it more than it's
teased right now
which is i like the way it looks but
getting getting all the knots out the
next day is like a [ __ ]
oh my god smoking so i gotta go oh my
god tom
i'm ready to come get you sandra hold on
i want my plane ticket ready take that
plane ticket to germany ready
oh my goodness i'm gonna give you some
of that real american
go ahead when he put that with the first
time you put that on i was like what's
up joe dirk
hold on stop talking about me
stop looking at me
[Music]
stop looking at me my god oh my god
[Laughter]
got that from i was uh
there's this guy subscribed to his
name's um
derek and derek got this channel called
more plates more dates and he's this
muscle nerd he's this real nerdy [ __ ]
dude who's big into like biochemistry
grandparents didn't know exactly
grantham's [ __ ] like steve when
steve was young
but he's like imagine if steve was
roided out he's like that he started off
as he's this muscle nerd he's all into
biochemistry and chemicals and [ __ ]
and he has all these [ __ ] protocols
and all these videos about
bio biotechnology and [ __ ]
hrt and well some nerds some nerds have
upgraded themselves
you know so
he also will tell you everything about
all these weird ass [ __ ] steroids
the history of and what they do and he's
got his blog going on
and people post to this blog and he
comments about the blog
and he has all these people talking
about their steroid [ __ ]
experiences and there was dude posted
some [ __ ] it's blowing my mind
oh oh man is it gonna blow your wig
right off 16 year old boy
running trenblen trent he was eating one
big
trend bologna sandwich and he talks
about what it did to his mind he ran it
as just solo a heavy dose at 16 while
he's going through puberty
he spent all his time
designing the technical [ __ ]
schematics and blueprints to make
cumbots
he called him cumbots okay i like that
which is like
sex bot is the perfect sex block
obviously
and he spent the other time his time
becoming racist and fighting against him
being racist
which he tells the whole story about
what that was all about and then a
[ __ ] uh uh fighting urges
uh from attacking women and he did
attack a few women he grabbed her
throats and [ __ ] and then he stopped
himself and jumped off and like
what did i do what he was doing
you attacked me bro i'm punching your
[ __ ] teeth no it's tren
he's on trend i don't give a [ __ ] what
it is yeah
on my end it doesn't really matter
trend is a molecule that kind of looks
like testosterone but it's [ __ ] a lot
you're it's a lot more targeting [ __ ]
muscle building
problem is it's so suppressive it shuts
down most of your endocrine system
you're never
ever ever supposed to run that just take
that on its own
okay but he doesn't know he's [ __ ] 16
year old kid
he takes that [ __ ] off you can't sleep
on it you will not be able to sleep it's
[ __ ] total insomnia
um because you're not producing because
you're not producing any testosterone
there's nothing to aromatize into
estrogen so you start
you can run on trend like it's test but
you won't have any estrogen so
you slowly start losing sanity on this
[ __ ]
your chemicals are [ __ ] totally
imbalanced
every time he saw a woman he felt like
he wanted a [ __ ] choker
a woman his age oh goodness he wanted
that's all
lots of hyper aggression that's all we
need so what he was doing was
wait he's only 16 16. oh my god okay i'm
like i'm punching you right now
all right every time he sees another he
goes to school and every time he sees a
16 year old girl
he has this [ __ ] overwhelming urge to
[ __ ] grab her throat
um maybe you guys should not have this
stuff
i'm just i'm just throwing that out so
then just throwing that so he does
is he needs a safe alternative so he
gets
he he locks himself up in his room this
is for several months
and writes out the blueprints to make
the perfect sex robots
yeah you make that yeah yeah you stay in
your house you call them combats
you just choke the robots right and
leave everyone else alone
and every time he's okay here's the deal
he's amerasian he's
he's half he's half caucasian he's half
asian
if he saw anybody if he saw p if he saw
anybody who
was asian or or black he would immediate
immediately [ __ ] think all kinds of
racist thoughts and [ __ ]
and um would try to become hostile
towards him
but then like a few minutes later he'd
[ __ ] shake himself out of it
and he would try to overcompensate so he
spent a lot of time buying [ __ ] hot
dogs and giving hot dogs to black people
to try to compensate for for for for for
the weirdest story i've ever heard yeah
man it's [ __ ] it's a great [ __ ] go
look at
more plates more and he just posted part
two because once he
showed up on the show he goes yeah and
on the blog he he goes into more detail
he even posted the schematics for making
the cumbots
he drew them all out when he was [ __ ]
high on trend
it's like high on trend it's [ __ ] his
mind was extreme oh my god my mind's
going back to frankenhooker again yeah
the whole like
okay hormones or hormones are extremely
powerful [ __ ]
influence over over personality and the
brain and the brain
this makes me want to never go outside
ever again
he was he's afraid that he's destroyed
his brain
but he went back to normal
but can we ever trust him again though
he's only like 17 or 18 right now can we
ever trust him again
yeah hormonal imbalance i don't know if
i would i don't know
i'm not going to extend that to him yeah
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] hilarious you got
to hear the [ __ ] stories the stories
that he
that he would do well not so funny to
somebody that's
like on the receiving end you know you
got to weigh the whole thing it's like
geez some random dude just jumped on me
and choked me out but then he bought me
a hot dog
so i don't know i don't know how i feel
about it he didn't choke anybody he just
he felt like he grabbed he grabbed a
girl by the throat but then let her go
as soon as he did
so he did kind of he did like assault
someone
evident but he knew her evidently it was
some girl in high school that doesn't
make it better
she didn't press charges on it that also
doesn't make it better
um but you know the influence of [ __ ]
trend that also does not make it better
he's a miner also does not make it
better
so you're just gonna hear the stuff 16
is old enough to know better you just
got to hear the stories
i mean i feel like i never had to be
told
that you shouldn't jump on people and
grab them by the throat randomly
i never had to be told that it was just
kind of understood
um you're thinking you're trying to read
too much into it
yeah okay you say that to me all the
time the dude is on trend he's [ __ ]
16 years old
no exciting all right
[Laughter]
yeah yeah it's okay he was on flakka he
gets a picture yeah no
well yeah that's what i'm saying no well
it's not
him it's not him he's under the
influence of the [ __ ] power
it's him but if you're on the like under
the influence of something i feel like
to an extent we can give you like a pass
but not
that's still you though it's still you
no
a lot of people still you a lot of
people have reported that
that well he's taking extremely high
doses of trend
right as a standalone and that was
actually
one of the symptoms uh aggression
towards women
and [ __ ] weird racist impulses
and it's just that that's one of the
things that it does
victor says maybe there was a carbon
monoxide leak and he was keeping her
from breathing it in
yeah she saved her by choking her but go
go that's what i mean it's like
you know if you want to get that
ridiculous go go get on
go go [ __ ] i'll [ __ ] show you [ __ ]
okay
he's got the charge i can imagine he's
got the drawings
he's got the drawings he's got the
[ __ ] schematics on how to make the
combos and [ __ ]
they are [ __ ] hilarious well everyone
should encourage him
and then to make the combats
and then don't come out of your house
ever again because none of us want to
deal
with your [ __ ] yeah it was temporary
it wore off
but none of us want to deal with your
temporary [ __ ]
here's the thing he said he said that he
started when he as he started when he
stopped taking it
it took him a few weeks to come back to
normal and he said that it was not
he said this should be good he said he
said
the combat fascination didn't stop
instantly
it slowly faded away and it became less
the idea became less and less attractive
until it got to the point where he
thought it was totally insane and had no
idea why he
why he even thought and then and then
everyone else was like
uh duh yeah where the [ __ ] have you been
i'm gonna show you guys [ __ ] i'm drunk
and i know that's like [ __ ] insane
come on well i was watching this and i
was going you know it sounds like a lot
of
[ __ ] things that serial killers
describe exactly
thank you very much well could it be
that maybe they're producing some kind
of weird biochemistry in their brain
that's possible
all right that's possible yeah well
because like i said i have read
many books about serial killers i read
that whole uh
that book there that um i think sophie
sent me that confessions of a serial
killer that was about btk
and it was about that woman that like
corresponded with him for a really long
time
the [ __ ] that the dude says like
somebody okay so
uh i think it was gary like earlier said
he wasn't actually gonna go to sleep
until you did the btk voice so at some
point you have to do that
we might want to get the bobble head
over here too like to weigh in on issues
but i read that dude the book and
she reproduced like a lot of the uh
correspondence she had got from him
and in a way
in a way it's terrifying because you're
just like holy crap like there's people
out there that look
relatively normal that think this way
but in another way it's kind of
i don't want to say it's like soothing
but it's like at least
like i don't think anything like this
dude like this dude's like thinking is
like completely alien to me
there it is right there
yeah that's uh that's not him that's
that's [ __ ]
um derek he's talking about this is a 16
year old
on trend combats brain damage and
becoming racist
and they just posted that you know what
that really like i almost want to
want to make a joke about that but i'm
not going to and then
the race is 16 year old sitting right
there man it's sitting right there
the racist 16 16 year old who decides
combat bots part two
part two is good too
probably two it's really good victor
says isn't there a high correlation
between serial killers and head injuries
yes there is yeah
um there is actually that's one of the
uh
factors that uh leads to a lot of them
had head injuries when they were
kids especially um
a lot of [ __ ] that happened to them in
child even ones that had like fairly
normal childhoods i think it's like you
know like phil
you know someone like fell off his wing
and [ __ ] like that
and uh hit their head so you know tom
yeah you had a head injury yeah
but later you didn't have a head injury
as a kid you were like older
i kind of feel like um serial killers
usually have head injuries when they're
young santa goes tom's pet all day
reading this weird rose blog no just
watch the videos he probably did yeah i
just watched the videos they were
commenting he spent all day watching the
weirdos videos
derek was talking about him in the
videos they're [ __ ] great i said i
sent it to
i sent part one to uh to sophie and she
loved it she goes man she goes that's
[ __ ] hilarious
he talks about it it's a [ __ ] great
story
but it makes me wonder if some of the
serial killer stuff
might be like biochemical and and
possibly organic well oh
yeah i'm sure there is a that's a fact
because
trend is doing things to certain [ __ ]
centers of the brain which would cause
reactions like that and it sounds kind
of like the urges of a serial killer
yeah like they see a woman and they just
can't help but yeah i gotta kill that
[ __ ]
well no yeah you love him but you want
to kill him at the same time and
he grabs her and goes oh and then he
stops himself and anybody who's
kind of like um anybody's a different
race
a different race okay here's another
thing he was half
asian and half caucasian
in part two he clarifies that
one time hat trend had him so bad
that he kept seeing nazi
nazi parades in his hair [ __ ] in his
hair and his head
let me [ __ ] sorry she's [ __ ]
naughty parades in his head
marching to heavy metal and then he's in
american history x
as the [ __ ] white dude and he's
stomping
he's curb stomping like in that movie
himself but the
asian version of himself paging dr freud
yeah yeah so the white version of
himself is killing off the [ __ ]
asian version of him you don't have to
be a psychotherapist yeah yeah well he
said that
in there yeah he's like
goodness gracious that dude has got like
some issues
xanada says jenny and tom i'm going to a
small goth nightclub in reno in two
weeks what's some pointers for me
don't talk to nobody well don't say that
jesus christ
i don't know man don't [ __ ] wear
black slacks
don't wear [ __ ] black dress shoes
[ __ ] it buy some [ __ ] boots and buy
some real shoes and buy some
yeah it's like i i kind of feel like
some place and i even saw look i even
saw
you know one of the orlando papers it
wasn't the cool one orlando weekly but
it was another one and they did an
article about mannequins
because uh paul vane posted it earlier
on facebook it was the dj there
and um they even said oh you know go
there
wear black i'm like that's a little
vague yeah don't just wear a black
because
i've seen [ __ ] showing i've
seen [ __ ] showing up in black
slacks and
yeah you look like a waiter go on go on
go on amazon that's like a uniform yeah
get you some [ __ ] demonia shoes
[ __ ] gots you can totally get away
with if you wear
cool boots and some [ __ ] pvc
[ __ ] demonia [ __ ] bondage pants or
something or [ __ ] you could even wear
black jeans and like a cool black
t-shirt like a band shirt yeah you could
totally get it with black jeans
uh just black even like old school you
could feel like doc martens you could do
something like that
the footwear is what is where the
[ __ ] the
a lot of guys notice your shoes and
i'm not going to lie about that goth or
punk rock footwear
you know what i mean and that's really
what makes the entire outfit
you could put a girl in a great outfit
and then you put her in [ __ ] up shoes
and yeah you're a [ __ ] poser
it's it's the shoes or the boots and i
feel like most goths
especially old school ones like totally
know that because we have a long history
of like people coming in goth clubs like
trying to like pass
yeah but they always get the shoes right
wrong for whatever reason they always
get the shoes wrong
i can go into a goth club with this bald
ass head
in this ten in this t-shirt with the
with the right pants as there are black
tight motorcycle pads that you can get
them they're like 60 bucks
and i would never wear them on a moto
they call them motorcycle pants i'd
never wear them on a motorcycle they'd
never survive a wreck
and and just a pair of new rock [ __ ]
boots
you know knee-high boots and i could
just
with the accessories you go in there and
it's summertime goth man
yeah no one even likes this yeah
whatever
now i mean everybody knows wintertime
you're probably gonna start looking at
the jackets and shirts and ties and [ __ ]
but you know we have our own things
it all depends on what look you're going
for yeah but i mean you can get away
with more casual [ __ ]
right but you can't just like
waltz in in like i said like a black
polo shirt black slacks like you'd wear
to work
no and black dress shoes no one's gonna
no one's gonna buy that
sorry and if you're a dude if you're
gonna wear a [ __ ] fishnet
shirt okay you either gotta be skinny or
you gotta be [ __ ]
buffed out all right and i'm not there
yet you wanna be like [ __ ] 10 percent
lean
in other words you know what 10 body fat
so you see the six pack of [ __ ] like
that
if you're skinny that'll work too if not
wear a t-shirt over the [ __ ]
fishnet shirt or under it but i actually
usually it's over it
okay yeah you don't see as much fishnet
as you use you don't see it like you
used to yeah you don't see it like
you wanted to wear the [ __ ] leather
rats and [ __ ] [ __ ]
leather [ __ ] bracelets yeah i mean
accessories
bracelets accessories are always good
yeah like get some cool belts with like
[ __ ] chains on them and [ __ ] like
that put some goggles on your head
motorcycle goggles or whatever kind of
goggles you want
or fancy like i said you can just do a
t-shirt and if you're a dude
you can just do t-shirts and pants but
it has to be the right t-shirts
general god dudes and shoes and general
goths don't have
facial hair if they do it's some satanic
[ __ ] anton levay
yeah you're right we don't really see a
lot of yeah
we don't really see a lot of facial hair
in the goth community
unless it's uh like you said unless it's
some anton lavey looking
unless you got like a goatee or like a
shirt merciless or anti
yeah that kind of [ __ ] you see that
sometimes other than that you don't
really see it much
all kind of different hair though i mean
especially among dudes you see bald
dudes you see mohawks you see
um just kind of real short hair you see
like the high and tight you see
i don't know lots of different [ __ ] uh
tina says what kind of shoes do gods
wear
and we're giving away all these [ __ ]
secrets to you pedestrian people
there's two there's two brands it's all
right everyone is everyone's friends
here
there's two brands no one's trying to
like passes anything the cheap brand is
demonia
it's cheap i've got several beers of
those yeah demonia tops out at about 140
for a pair of boots and they're like you
know like knee-high
yeah and it's pretty with a bunch of
buckles it's pretty good they last
a while if you dance in a lot because i
danced in them a lot
so i've had several pairs and they've
like worn out after your time like the
heel will fall off or they'll bust open
you want platforms on you want lots of
buckles and you want lots of spikes and
[ __ ] like that
the top-notch [ __ ] which that's that's
where that's where i'm at
by the time it's not [ __ ] it is because
it lasts forever
all right and that's uh new rock
new rock it's an italian company it's
all leather
[ __ ] fantastic [ __ ] souls that's
what you see a lot of the metal and
thrash bands and
and people in bands where they wear new
rock either the shoes or the boots and
they make
men's and women's new rock men's men's
boots or shoes are [ __ ] fantastic
boots gonna cost you about 350. all
right
but you keep them for a lifetime they'll
last [ __ ] yeah they last a long time
but like i said they're real leather and
they're handmade
yeah i got a pair of new rock boots that
i've had for how long
is it i can't even remember what eight
years and then the shoes
i've had for [ __ ] 12 13. you had
those before i met you yeah
12 13 years so that's more than 11. and
uh
the sole separated from the thing a
little bit like they do i just use
shoe glue and put weights on it and
[ __ ] glued it back together just the
same way you would do it at a shoe
repair place
and you can keep those things running
forever david june says i wear chuck
taylors
but i'm not goth i like comfy shoes
chuck taylors are totally acceptable
doc martens would be entry and that'd be
like i mean chuck taylors are more like
well
a lot of like skaters and shay used to
wear those so it's like chuck taylor's i
feel like i had
several pairs of chuck taylors myself i
had some high top uh black
chalk tailors back in the day so you
know those are acceptable also
but uh he's saying like glad to see tom
sees us all as pedestrian jeez i thought
you liked us bro
what do you say he said glad to see tom
sees us all as pedestrian jeez i thought
you liked us bro
yeah well we're working right now you
know what i mean
[Laughter]
big difference between the show and the
club all right
although it was funny me and january at
the club and [ __ ] we had a listener
approach us at the club we didn't i even
know the guy he goes look man i don't
mean to bother you but i'll [ __ ]
i'm a listener i love your show i was
like oh man thanks man i appreciate it i
was so hammered i was a note
i was in no shape to talk to the dude
yeah if we're out we're usually like
one we're so drunk and i am uh i don't
know if a lot of you know this but i am
half
deaf yeah so if you come up to me and
talk to me at the club
i will probably smile at you and nod and
stuff but i will probably have no idea
what you're saying
and when i'm at the club i can't hear
[ __ ] and when i'm at the club i'm so
mentally far away from the show it's
just not you know what i mean
this is like work for us in in a way i
have fun at the show yeah
yeah but it's like a different scene
it's different scene yeah
that's kind of like we're not really i
mean sometimes we think about it because
sometimes early in the night before we
drink we're just like oh we need to do
this that and the other we'll like talk
about
it what we're going to do the show
tomorrow or whatever and also there's a
big difference when you're
you know i'm i'm letting y'all into this
in on this [ __ ] you know i mean as a
[ __ ]
old [ __ ] goth dude
when you're goth like us and you're in
mixed company
in public that's one thing it's a lot
more open if you're at a certain club
where it's a mixture of goth people
and regular people that's another thing
too it's kind of like you're on
different settings
but if you're at the [ __ ] castle
during a full dressed
full-on yearly annual event yeah because
sometimes they have like some big
[ __ ] yeah
like the vampire ball the steampunk
ballers your settings aren't on 10
they're on
11. although vampire ball if you just
came up normal they would not let you in
no right
so when you're this is like a [ __ ] a
holy
[ __ ] religious ceremony for us so
when we're set on 11
oh hell no we're not going to talk to
y'all
[ __ ] no [ __ ] because well like i said
when you're in
church with us no we're in that
situation yeah it's totally
normally they would not get in you
wouldn't even get in normally you
wouldn't get in right because
and i've been to like parties like that
especially like god parties fetish party
stuff like that sometimes they have a
dress code
most places in orlando so they don't
want to do that because they just want
all the money
yeah but um tampa like the castle will
do
like some special events like i said
vampire ball is kind of their big one
uh they do a steampunk ball too i don't
know if they do it anymore but they do
like a couple like that every year and
they have a very very very strict dress
code
you're not like all [ __ ] decked out
nope right nope
and then me and jenny would be in the we
got pictures of us in this situation too
we'll be in the gothic sphere
okay where it's just goth on goth action
and [ __ ]
and it all and and these and have these
people are [ __ ] now okay
that's [ __ ] cattiness and infighting
and [ __ ] all kinds of status involved
and all right talking to that
[ __ ] and here they're down here
and i'm up here and it's
this it's a the goth universe is a
hierarchy okay
in that way some people they're just
like oh fine
it's just happening we're not like that
i'm not that much
it depends on the situation well we're
kind of like that well it depends on
your situation
it's situational thank you david right
thank you david
just because that tyrell shirt is so
fantastic yeah thank you i'm glad you
enjoyed that
[ __ ] i asked for it jenny delivered
man she found what we needed
and it's one of my favorites i have two
of them and i've actually come out very
nice i've worn these to the club and
they were a big hit they were like man
that's a cool shirt
it's like you want one give me twenty
dollars
[Laughter]
we need to like wear one of the ouija
board shirts because that was my
favorite one of this last cycle well
this is really good with like the
industrial motif
it is yeah because that's kind of like
well you know the i kind of feel like
well even like
you know graham at the [ __ ] god club
he wears that like yeah that
weyland-yutani
yeah one that he i don't know where he
got that from
man they're doing his oh this weekend
they're doing this is gonna be
interesting
uh at mannequins they're doing goth
pimps and hoes
yeah yeah goth vincent house that was
gina's idea
yeah well i did the poster
and i was just kind of like i had a
really hard time like coming up with
like what
i've never heard of like a goth pimps
and hoes party i was like that just
seems like two
audiences that are not uh that don't
overlap
but we'll see we'll see what happens t
that says do peeps at the clubs watch
your show like no they don't
they don't some of our friends do watch
it sometimes sometimes yeah they don't
really
uh when there's a dude that
he was about my age and we were at we
were at mannequins and
he was goth adjacent he was the goth guy
got the jason
well i haven't seen him in full dress
right he was just it was summertime yeah
i mean
and he came up he just was like man i
love you guys showed me to bother you
and he was [ __ ] real respectful it
was good i liked it because
i was [ __ ] hammered i didn't have
time i you know i would not have been
able to handle
somebody just wanting to talk about the
show you know what i mean
yeah just [ __ ] was because like man
when i'm drunk some and i'm just like
listening to the music and sometimes
like i don't mind it
um as long as people are like not weird
and like clingy and stuff
if you just come up and be like man i
think your show is awesome yeah that's
cool and everything right but it's like
if you're going to ask me details i'm
not
yeah yeah we're not going to remember
i'm not going to remember and and i'm
not going to hear half of what you say
and we're not really going to want to
talk about that we're going to be more
in the situation of that club
at the time we're going to be [ __ ]
partying so you want to talk
we're going to talk about partying don't
talk about the show that's where we can
talk later but like
later but not when we're in there you
can go to chantals with us get some
chicken and waffles then we'll talk but
also we'll be super [ __ ] up and we
probably won't remember anything you say
yeah when i'm in the club i can't a mini
movie doesn't watch
for all i know that [ __ ] does he
might i don't know yeah he never
comments
he never comments unless he's like an
incognito
but he's got some he's got more little
slaves and [ __ ] that he's dealing with
well you know what's weird is that
sometimes
i don't realize because remember when um
our friend asandra
who we met at eyebar like a long time
ago she's been
man she has been in the club scene in
orlando since she was 17
and she's the same age as me um so she's
been like going to eye bar and [ __ ] like
that
like forever and we uh i hadn't seen her
for a while and then she was at uh
mannequins the other day so i got to
talking to her and she's like oh i
wanted to talk to you about like because
i want to start a podcast i want to like
talk to you and so she came over to the
house the other day
we had a drink and we were talking about
[ __ ] and she said
she's like you know i listen to you guys
shows sometimes she like brought up a
couple things that we like talked about
on show she doesn't like listen to it
like regularly because like i said
our [ __ ] asses are on all the time it's
like no one can keep up
but she had seen like a bunch of shows
um so
it's kind of like i don't know we don't
have any like super super regular
listeners but a lot of people that we
know at the clubs like do listen
sometimes
yeah like if it's something that they
you know
care about or some topic or is there
anything
in the mood if they're in the mood like
to listen to it so some of them because
some of them will come up to me and
they'll be like hey i saw your show
about blah blah blah
and then we'll talk about that but it's
like i don't know if there's like any of
them that like listen
super regularly another thing is is that
y'all's experience of us
and our friends experience of us is very
different
they see us all the time at the club
yeah we're not that interesting
we're not interesting enough to like
watch yes they could be like oh it's
damn damn them yeah yeah
we talk to them all the time that's part
of it another part of it is that they
know that
they all do work similar to this they're
all most of them are artistic people
we don't watch their [ __ ] either and
it's not you know
or watch all their shows like they're
spinning live on
yeah it's like sometimes we do but it's
like i don't really
yeah yeah but it's like sometimes i
don't really have time because a lot of
our friends are
in bands or they have like radio shows
or something like that
and i try to go on there and like
support but i don't have time to like
support
everybody they got their gigs and we got
our games and
our our our relationship is not
professional it's personal
from the clubs well in a lot of ways we
don't really care too much i mean
we we like the fact that yeah you do
this he's in that bad and this is
but that's not the center of our yeah we
just like them because they're cool
people and we've known them for like
forever
right we're not fans wear peers with
them
so it's not this it's not this well like
for an example like
we know we help each other what like we
know brian
like the vegan black metal chef yeah um
have i seen a lot of his videos yes i've
seen a lot of his uh
videos like a lot of his cooking videos
and i designed his cookbook
i don't watch every single one that
comes out i mean i liked all the ones
that came out but it's like you know
because we see him all the time
yeah and ben v and ludovico like
yeah it's like do i do i buy his like
cds sometimes
sure misfit toys um but yeah we
we know them in real life so it's like
it's not every now and then we'll like
buy their [ __ ] or
you know go see their shows or whatever
but it's like it's not we're not
constantly up their ass because we know
them some of the girls we know are kind
of like
only fans girls and [ __ ] porn type
people and [ __ ] we don't watch their
[ __ ]
we don't really care about that you know
i mean [ __ ] exotic looking and and
it's just
tough they're you know we're like those
big boob girls you know i mean we don't
really care
that's just them we hang out with them
when when we're at the club
and everybody's kind of florida's kind
of like like i said i'm from california
in florida it's
a lot like california was back in the
70s and the 80s it's kind of
kind of an artistic crowd you know
it's a little it's not as built up it's
it's more it's more suburban which
that's the way california used to be
when i was a kid
i mean it had it had city areas but we
have that here too miami and orlando are
pretty big orlan of miami much bigger
than well in tampa st
peak clearwater is even much better yeah
much better tampa
yeah because that's like a three city
yeah it's a triangle people from new
york are moving here and [ __ ] it up
and people are moving it pete y'all will
eventually move here and [ __ ] it up
probably
but i'll be an old man i'll i'll be an
old man by by the time all that happens
he's so crotchety i'll be an old man
there's no crotch anytime
yeah it's going to take 20 years for you
guys to [ __ ] this up and by then i won't
people have been moving here from new
york since i was a child
yes so don't get too like [ __ ] [ __ ]
up
like my grandpa used to complain about
that i got his yankees moving down here
my grandpa used to say
back in [ __ ] 1982. well i say that
and [ __ ] like a lot of our friends
you sound just like you sound just like
my grandpa
a lot of our friends little swells from
new york imani is from there he's from
new york a lot of our friends are from
new york yeah they're from new york but
upstate new york not new york city but
you know what i mean but those those are
cool new yorkers
although i tell you what you know when i
used to go to new york from boston
new yorkers are a lot cooler than than
bostonians they're they're
not as i [ __ ] loved new york they got
more
i've been there like lots and lots of
times and i loved it there
i loved it there i could easily live
there if i could afford it but i cannot
yeah new yorkers born and raised in new
york got balls
and and they got good personalities i
like how cranky they are because that
kind of like goes in with my own
natural crankiness yeah but they also
adapt pretty well here
you know what i mean yeah they they come
here and they go oh yeah it's different
but i like it i like it like this
they're not trying to turn it into new
york
it's got its own thing here you know um
and the the the the the new york that
made new york great in my mind was the
new yorker the 70s and the 80s anyway
when it was all gummy when it was kind
of scummy kind of like the
detroit when i was living in an industry
i honestly kind of miss the scumminess
like it's nicer nowadays that you can go
there and like probably not get mugged
because i feel like in the 70s and 80s
like some parts of it were like really
dangerous
um you know what i mean and i kind of
remember that whole vibe of it like when
you went later
you could still you could go to like a
lot pretty much anywhere and you'd
be okay like you didn't really worry
that much about it they say it's getting
bad again though now
it's it it's getting the crimes go way
up
a lot of people are leaving dj maniac
was talking about and i guess he's
talking about vegan black metal chef uh
brian he says brian is an absolute
delight oh dude yeah right cool
he is a lovely lovely i know you know
him
brian's been over to the house several
times we had parties here he wanted to
come over here and learn how to make
pizza
yeah he came up with like he brought
some food to that party at that time
when he had a party here he brought food
and we made vegan food and he brought
some vegan food as well he loved
he loved my um um vegan uh indian food
what was that that was uh
yeah what'd you make from that time it
was i think you made that thing with the
chickpeas
yeah it was chickpeas i forgot what it
was called though
yeah the chickpea curry yeah you just
made like a bakery it was vegan
yeah it was good he loved he's oh man
this is great it was really good yeah
[Laughter]
a lot of people ate that i had uh
chickpea curry and
we just saw we just saw him at some
couple days ago memento
oh i got a video of him [ __ ] with me
remember well actually that's when they
put the damn dick on my shoulder oh this
one yes
so it was the last memento and he's
sitting there i'm talking to him he's
talking to me about pizza
pizza and i got this [ __ ] [ __ ] a
towel
him and his wife come over here his wife
his wife is jen
from 13th angel all right she's one of
the background
she's one of the vote she's the female
vocalist for 13 angels
um but you guys have probably seen her
so dimitri also had works in the
hotel industry yeah he's like a hotel
manager
and he came up through the ranks and he
knows all these [ __ ]
hotel skills and one thing they do is he
fold towels on his pretty ways yeah
but he can also fold a towel and make it
look just like a [ __ ] just like a dick
yeah
and he i wasn't looking at him and him
and little swell were standing behind me
and [ __ ] he folds a [ __ ]
napkin up a towel a little hand towel he
folds it up like a [ __ ] big old
tennis [ __ ] he lays that [ __ ] over my
[ __ ] shoulder
and i'm sitting there talking drunk
[ __ ] being serious and they're back
they're filming me [ __ ] going look at
him
he's so jacked he can't feel it yeah me
and demetri and matt were back there
like
because like for i was like oh my god he
still is like like let's see how long it
takes for him to notice that that's
his shoulder so i'm talking about i'm
talking to vegan black metal chef with
the damn [ __ ] hanging over my shoulder
it was funny you know
it was very funny and i couldn't believe
how long
it sat there without you realizing
and put it in the pants and let that
[ __ ] [ __ ] hang out on my [ __ ]
pants
and and [ __ ] just went right back
like nothing ever happened
and i'm [ __ ] walking around through
the club with a [ __ ] big old [ __ ]
[ __ ] hanging out of my [ __ ] pants for
uh how long was that maybe about two or
three minutes yeah so and um
forgot all about it if i could talk it
to the bartender and they're still back
there chuckling and laughing that [ __ ]
swinging
and then [ __ ] some big old tall
[ __ ] hot goth girls come around the
corner go oh my they go
oh and they're [ __ ] giggling and [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah
but they stopped videotaping the part
where i picked picked it up
i guess they were running out it was
just like a short clip it ran out well
because that's what we were laughing at
was that you were just like sitting
there talking like nothing
funny when i flipped it back around on
them see
well no it's just that we didn't know
that was going to happen subsequently
we were just filming it because we
thought it was funny that you didn't
realize it was there and he was like
talking like it was normal
thank you gadgey3 have this because i'm
drunk as a mofo
yeah that's duper getting there although
i need another and the football went
good
okay did it okay all right all right the
sports ball went the way that you wanted
it together
with you uh
that says tom's southern man is kicking
in and
dammit southern man
i hear screaming and bull whips cracking
and how long how long that's a great
song i like this song actually i do too
actually yeah
tom dancing or glenn ross uh tom dancing
yeah i think it's time for more drinks
go ahead sandra just said i just
discovered new rock boots
that i love this goth waltz i'm really
slowly turning into a goth yes you're
gonna be a [ __ ] peanut butter goth
eating girl
yeah we'll see right a peanut a goth
eaten peanut butter girl
wait a goth eating pizza she's gonna eat
goths oh no
yeah now our house is decorated goth
tila
our bedroom is [ __ ] red yeah not so
much the outside part of it but like
the bedroom's red with black trim and we
have like a lot of horror posters we
have the thing
with the shiny guy yeah
i have a uh this really cool piece of
artwork that i bought at a horror
convention many years ago
which is cupcake cthulu which is like
this girl and she has like all these
tentacles and like cupcakes and stuff
um what else do we have what other movie
posters do we have i think we have a
casino royale one which is actually
looks like a
like a playing card he's talking about
me with this [ __ ] wig and the shadows
hitting my eye like i got i have not
eyeliner and eye makeup on
tila you don't understand when i got my
[ __ ] long hair on man i'm [ __ ]
beautiful
beautiful oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you i'm being eaten alive by hair
hold on hold on join the club yeah this
is why i want you i got my pretty wig on
i wanted to do it you're so pretty oh
yeah because this one
this is why i wanted to cut most of my
hair off this is like why
my this is my everyday experience do you
understand that
it's like a hair or something else man
every single day every time i try to do
anything
it seems like i'm either getting the
hair in my mouth or it's like caught in
my
fingernails or something or there's like
pieces of it
like caught in my bra for christ's sake
hair
everywhere i wanted to like shave my
head completely we were talking about
this at the club the other night
was when i decided i was like yeah i'm
gonna go back to like the shade at least
partially shaved i might shave all of it
i'm not sure but i do kind of like the
mohawk action
and um i was kind of like man i wish my
head wasn't so
enormous so i could just like shave it
all off and then
i could just be bald and then if i felt
like it i could wear a wig because
hair is uh overrated and i wish
that i had a head that could support
baldness
i don't think i can though because i
just feel like my head is too
i don't know i feel like my head is too
big and i don't think i would look bald
um i was thinking about doing a chelsea
like vampira used to do back in the day
so it would have been like the bangs and
this but
nothing else and tom was kind of like
i don't know i feel like you have to be
really really skinny to do that and i
was like gee thanks a lot
um but yeah so i don't know i think my
head's too big to do that kind of [ __ ]
i need like hair in the back as much as
i don't want it there
i do want it there because i like the
way it looks but i don't want it there
because it's like too much of a pain in
the ass i don't like to wash it i don't
like to brush it i don't like to like
maintain it it's just too much trouble
but
i can't be bald because that looks
really crappy so
uh it's a conundrum uh thank you david
you all need to rent 976 evil from
amazon um
i saw it a long time ago and i really
liked it but i haven't seen it
again since then i'd buy the dvd for you
but it's a bit too pricey so here's a
rental
thank you very much thank you very much
i'm gonna write that down
because that was one of the ones that i
wanted to do eventually
because it has that dude i mean you know
it was robert england right and it has
that dude that was in fright night who i
love
um i saw it on cable once or twice
back in the old days and i remember
liking it but i haven't seen it a long
time since then so it's one of those
ones that i kind of want to rewatch to
see if it's
any good uh cheryl stanley says i'm
putting go to a goth club on my bucket
list
they're usually pretty fun i mean
i don't know it's hard to find like a
completely
i don't even know what the word is like
a completely like
god club where like there's nobody there
but that
because you usually get bleed through
but really economically
there's not enough goths in any one city
to like support a club of any
significant size because it's kind of
expensive to run them especially like in
orlando because
the liquor licenses alone are just
ridiculous
um so even like mannequins where we go
you know our friend
big tom opened that and
even he has he's open most nights friday
nights and saturday nights
they do not just go it's goth industrial
new wave um even like last friday
or last saturday he was doing like some
old like hair metal like he's playing
guns and roses and [ __ ]
um because one there was one girl that
was like requesting it
um so you get like in downtown sanford
too
you get a lot of kind of yuppy action
because there's a lot of other clubs
around there or like a lot of other kind
of bars
that are kind of like sports bars and
stuff so you get like a lot of spillover
from that because mannequins is like
open later
than those because those usually close
by 11. so
you get a lot of that um downtown
orlando you don't get so much of that
because i guess there's more different
types of clubs so
everybody that comes to barbarella which
is we called ibarr
which used to be called barbarella um
everybody kind of knows what
that the deal with that place is because
it's been there for like 35 years or
whatever
so it's like everybody knows eight you
know saturday night is 80s night
um so that's kind of like when you're
gonna get the goths the punks the new
wave people
gonna get younger people that like 80s
uh music too
but it's kind of like an alt more
alternative crowd you know what i mean
so thank you check this out jay what
what'd you do
i had to change my drink because i ran
out of
pineapple oh no i got cake vodka
yeah and guava taste it it's right there
i don't like guava though
just taste it he always makes me just
taste that [ __ ]
that's that's really good
that's pretty good it's kind of sweet
yeah that's very sweet
i was saying it's really south america
man it's very very sweet that's even too
sweet for me and i love sweet [ __ ]
um yeah i was commenting on the uh on
cheryl stanley's comment
that i'm putting go to a goth club on my
bucket list
and i was saying uh what's up ian
askberry
um firewoman
do it no i heard that on my [ __ ]
pants i heard that on my pandora the
other day and i had to skip it
it's like it's kind of crooked
she's driving me crazy come on
come on i don't remember the lyrics i
just heard that song like two days ago
and i can't even
i'm not a big fan of the cult i gotta
say
i don't know why do you know the cult
taylor doesn't know the cult
taylor's not coming see you're feeling
my but you're feeling my pain with like
tina's not caucasian enough to to know
the cult you know the cult she watched
she's gonna [ __ ] with me because i know
the cult i have three of their albums
well maybe she does yeah you're like
don't like don't presume
i'm presuming actually i look like the
damn singer from [ __ ] lybach now
you do a bit yeah i'm like a lie back or
crazy
yeah really good well no i didn't mean
that in a bad way
yeah i actually quite like nice
life is life they're like yeah i look
like
the impaler yeah
i mean on the whole i like industrial
music i'm not saying that
but i don't know i feel i like it at
club but honestly i kind of like more
i like post punk [ __ ] i like death rock
i like
old school punk rock i like weird [ __ ]
there comes a point where a lot of
industrial just kind of sounds the same
to me
and i feel like that was kind of like
when i when i started going to the
castle
when i was going to the castle in like
the late 90s
and early 2000s i kind of feel like that
was a problem that i had
was that they played a lot of
industrial noise um
you know just a lot of synth pop a lot
of stuff like that and a lot of it
didn't really make an impression
because a lot of it kind of sounded the
same like some of the bands you could
pick out because like you know the
singers were distinctive or the style
was distinctive but not a lot a lot of
it just kind of like blended together
tila says um i was right this she
doesn't know anything about the cult
i just feel like like i said they
started out
um as a death rock band southern death
cult
um and i liked them i wasn't a big fan i
didn't buy any of their albums or
anything but it's like you know when i
heard their songs i'm like oh that's
good
but then like when like the late 80s
came along they kind of went
more la glam metal yeah type of
direction which
sisters of mercy did too but not to the
same extent is that
so i kind of feel like by the time that
love came out that album i kind of felt
like well they kind of just sound like
everybody else
so i lost interest you know what i'm
saying they still play
a ton of cult songs at
you know any goth or new wave club you
go to
um they still play that but
i don't know i just can't get into it it
sounds too much like glam metal to me
that's the cup also kind of dorsy
they're very dorsey the music sounds
like ac dc
but this but ian asbury sounds like jim
morrison yeah although i will say he
doesn't sound as much like jim morrison
as ian mcculloch from eck on the bonyman
does
and i would argue that echoing the
bunnymen sounds more like the doors than
the cult does
yeah maybe people i saw them live they
opened up for billy idol they were
[ __ ] great
oh i'm sure they're probably good live
it's just not i don't know they
to me they just didn't seem like they
had enough to like their sound was not
like
um distinct enough for me to really
super get into them
that's all they were mainstream of the
day yeah that's what i'm saying but when
they were the southern death cult they
were really good yeah i liked it
i liked that yeah because like i said
they sounded like a death rock band back
then
then they just started kind of sounding
like everybody else which i'm sure it
was good for them because i'm sure they
made a [ __ ] ton of money
but you know i was just kind of like
yeah i'm out
i'm out i don't know i i kind of like
more quirky
at least have i i like bands that as
soon as that [ __ ]
as soon as that song comes on even if
you've never heard that song
before you know exactly who that is you
know what i'm saying
i like that yeah i can't play any of the
music because uh we'll get a copyright
strike
if you guys want to open a uh another
window and listen to the cult
i would probably either listen to she
sells sanctuary or firewoman
yeah four throw down said when she sell
sanctuary comes on is a good time to go
to the bar
exactly that's exactly what happens yeah
i'll be out there dancing to something
cool like the cramps or mark almond or
something
and then the coal to come on and i'll be
like oh well i wanted to rest my feet
anyway
and then i go then i go get a drink or i
go out to the back patio to smoke or
something
oh uh yeah i used to i've heard india
ire i've also heard stevie wonder
that was top 40. well not india irene
but i
and i don't remember much about india
ivory
yeah but do you remember do you remember
shaw day
she was good i liked shelby yeah yeah
all of her [ __ ] was good
she had another song too that was like
she had a bunch of circular yeah she had
a bunch she had a lot of stuff
i know smooth operator was like her kind
of big hit like her big breakout hit but
she had like several other than that
even into the very late 90s
2000s she had a good uh she had
some good uh songs video and everything
yeah well you know and i think i
mentioned this before it's like i think
people have
because we were talking about this in
the context of when we were at
mannequins one night
and there was a bunch of these like
really obnoxious like normal people
there
and they i think they thought they were
like owning us
or something by asking the dj to play
the bee gees
and i'm like [ __ ] yeah we know the bg's
too dance the [ __ ] out of me i know that
i know all the words that [ __ ] and
here's another thing man
[Laughter]
i like the bee gees these dudes jump on
the dance floor to be like five of them
all right we call them mundanes all
right
if you're not gothic then you're mundane
okay so that's okay well that's the
ethnic slur against y'all
it is well it's kind of like the harry
potter universe it's kind of like we're
calling you muggles
yeah it's kind of it's a similar monday
muggles so like five dudes jump on the
dance floor and they're [ __ ] dancing
and
they all have like cargo shorts yeah
cargo shorts
they're they're trying to dance they're
trying to goof on us and goof on the
music so what do i do i jump right in
the middle of them and start romp riding
one of them
and the other ones pull out the phone
and the dude's [ __ ] submitting to it
and then [ __ ] and then his buddy's like
pulling him away and said no don't do
that and [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] leather daddy in these
[ __ ] and [ __ ] they're young guys
you know what i mean
they've back up and just look looking at
me kind of chuckling and i go well at
least you all didn't run away and then
they laughed and ran
because sometimes they do because a lot
of times they run away because we've
done that at eye bars sometimes
yeah like if somebody got in there
if you're gonna goof on the [ __ ]
music and goof photos i'm a goof on you
we'll see now what happened this past i
can't remember if it was friday or
saturday because we went both nights
um he was playing like some good [ __ ]
like he was playing like some kind of
hardcore like he was playing like some
older industrial and i was like and i
told you i said you know what he should
play now
stigmata yeah i was like so we can start
a uh
you know a mosh pit it because that's
what inevitably happens at a goth club
whenever you play ministry stigmata
so it's like he was reading my mind
because the next song that came on was
stigmata and i was like [ __ ] yeah so i'm
like [ __ ] doing my thing
and then there's this group of like five
or six
normal people and they had been dancing
to something earlier
but i guess they decided they want to
like save their place on the dance floor
so they're just gonna stand there
they're not gonna dance they're just
standing
yeah and if there's one thing i hate and
i've
kicked people on at eyebar for this too
no parking on the dance floor if you're
not gonna [ __ ] dance
get the [ __ ] off you're in everyone's
way and if you're a girl
do not put your purse down on the
[ __ ] center on the middle of the
dance floor dude there's places to hang
that stuff yeah
they do that they come in what is with
the ring of girls with the purses in the
middle
they just don't know any better what is
that about bad club etiquette
they'll come in and they'll put the
purses down and they'll all dance in a
ring
it seems like common sense it seems like
common sense and
another thing [ __ ] it seems like
common sense too if you're not dancing
get off the dance floor you are in
everyone's way
even when other people are dancing
around you and like trying not to elbow
you
except maybe elbowing you like
accidentally on purpose which i will
totally do
yeah because i'm passive aggressive like
that yeah but it's just kind of like
move don't go to a golf club move and
get on the dance floor
don't be a hipster and go on go to the
go to a goth club and get on the dance
floor and try to be
ironic and do the robot and [ __ ] you're
gonna get goofed on
i goofed on a [ __ ] doing that i
tried to dry hump him and crawl up into
his [ __ ] pants
and he [ __ ] left all right do not
[ __ ] goof
on the dance floor like just be cool why
is that hard
okay don't try to like call attention to
yourself you're not mo
you're not awesome you're not like just
you're not
you're not clever you're not awesome
it's yeah we've seen it a million
it's a zillion times it's going back
like 20
30 years we have seen behavior like that
and it's not funny it's not cute it's
not anything
you're just being a douche and you're
tiresome so it's just kind of like
move just move yeah and you can't reason
me out of it i'm a [ __ ] kamikaze
everyone's tired sometimes they're like
what are you gay and i says we're both
going to be gay here in a minute
you know i mean i lean right into that
[ __ ] bad [ __ ] and i'm just going you
know
that booty's gonna be mine sexy as
you're dancing on this dance floor
turn around turn around and i'll call
you a girl i'm gonna refer to you in
female terms
turn around girl if [ __ ] and then go
look at that and i'll point at your
booty and i'll go
if me [ __ ] an ass as tight as that
makes me gay then i'm guessing i'm just
[ __ ] gay because i'm like
how could a man resist and [ __ ] it
cracks them it breaks them
because what are they gonna do well
they're not entirely sure they're not
sure
how to react how to react to it because
they don't know if you're joking or not
yeah and i want to make it
very unclear it's going to be very
unclear
that's the [ __ ] power okay that i'm
going to put on you all right
if if you piss me off we're gonna [ __ ]
or
somebody's gonna [ __ ] somebody honestly
if it's me
i will probably just like trip you
accidentally yeah well
yeah me i'm gonna try to [ __ ] you or put
an elbow in your face
accidentally oops
didn't see you there that's what i'll do
[Laughter]
you shouldn't be just so dancing so
close to other people what are you doing
and if toby's there that leather daddy's
gonna [ __ ] you up man
if he sees me [ __ ] with you then he's
gonna come really [ __ ] with it's
gonna be like having rob halford on you
he's gonna have the [ __ ] he's gonna
have the [ __ ] leather vest
because he doesn't really have much
patience for that and he hadn't been
impatient with that [ __ ] and he's older
than we are
so he has even less balance i'm gonna
tell you something this is absolutely
true
he'd be out there on a dance floor and
[ __ ] mesmerizing women and i said
jenny look at that [ __ ] bulge
his [ __ ] his [ __ ] [ __ ] wraps
around the [ __ ] side of his leg
and ends and something looks like a
goddamn apple that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] genetically gifted
i was talking to his boyfriend one time
i said you take that
he had a black boyfriend at that time so
you take that [ __ ] because i take all
that [ __ ]
it's like you [ __ ] are terrible
man you guys are [ __ ] bad
just like god damn that dude is that
dude is [ __ ]
i haven't seen toby in so long though so
it was like we saw a couple weeks ago
yeah it's like he came out like this
past weekend and i was like so [ __ ]
happy because i didn't see him
like [ __ ] well he works a lot
he's a nurse so it's like we haven't
seen him a long time so it's like he
came out to mannequins i was like [ __ ]
what it's like come dance with me right
now he doesn't like hanging out in gay
clubs he likes to hang out straight
clubs and goth clubs and stuff and
fetish stuff
he doesn't like he doesn't like he's
kind of he's more like a guy yeah he's
more like a gothic he doesn't like
mainstream gay scenes and he's older
than us too he's like 50
55 something he's 50 something yeah
i mean he you know he only did of course
he only dates gay guys but he doesn't
like the kc
and uh he thinks it's too [ __ ]
mainstream
he says this too well see that's what i
mean it's kind of like
he says it's too [ __ ] milk too that's
what i mean i don't like to be like two
like normal people but you know what i
mean it's kind of like
it's a we have our own thing yeah and
it's like it's weird because it's kind
of like
gay straight it's like that matters less
than like
are you into the same like [ __ ] that
i'm into are you into the same like
[ __ ] music that i'm into it's that
kind of thing i'm going to get this [ __ ]
off video man cause it's true
i got some i do have some videos of him
dancing got it
we do have a yeah we have on my
instagram because we took a couple
i need to get pictures of him dancing on
a [ __ ] friday night
at [ __ ] eye bar for the new wave
night
and there'd be all these mainstream
girls
[ __ ] around him in a [ __ ] circle
watching him [ __ ] dance
because he's super [ __ ] hot yeah and
they don't super hot they don't realize
maybe they realize he's gay but they're
just wistfully watching this [ __ ]
and maybe not though because okay
we gave him a ride home i'm trying to
turn him straight i'm like i'll try to
disturb this
i tried to turn him straight i was like
dude you got so much to offer these
women how are you gonna deny them that
he's like oh you shut the [ __ ] up
i said dude how are you gonna deny that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] monster you got to
these [ __ ] women right here look at
him
and he's like i'm not drunk enough for
that and we look and when when he gets
really [ __ ] up he's all over
he's all over well you gotta get in a
reference [ __ ] i said look man
yeah it's gone pretty good i'm not into
this lesbian [ __ ] going on here between
y'all
okay [ __ ] it
it's funny though it is it is
actually kind of funny and he's like i i
love all of you guys
so you're going too far you're going to
am i disrespected
he's so awesome but like we've given him
a ride home a couple of times
like two or three times yeah and he's
always kind of like
do i seem gay to you guys yeah yeah he
asked me to uh do i seem gay you like
talking and i'm like
honestly i knew him a long time before i
realized i don't know he just he didn't
read as gay to me
no not at first um once you know him
you see it though yeah once you know him
like really well you do but it's like
it's kind of like [ __ ] all the time to
me you [ __ ]
it just didn't occur to me i don't know
it didn't occur to me tom tom says yeah
what's up bro
do i seem gay to you yeah and you can't
don't say yeah you go
no man of course not it's good
he's sucking he's honestly seriously i
knew him for a while it was like he
never read his game it was like
let's see honestly it really never
occurred to me
i didn't think about it one way or the
other yeah um
i don't know it's just that's something
that i don't think about i just like i
meet a person and i'm just like hey this
is
a cool person it's not it's a cool
person it's not the first impression
that you
so i don't like really think about it
either way i don't think about oh is
this person straight i don't i don't
really think about that
i just thought he was a [ __ ] goth
kind of bondage fetish type dude
right and like i said in the goth scene
you don't really like you're not looking
at that you don't really think about it
because i don't really care yeah no no
one really cares because like is this a
cool person okay
this is a cool person then you're not
really like concerned about
what goth is almost kind of like a
sexual orientation to begin with
you know what it kind of is now that you
bring it up
because it's something that honestly
like
my whole entire teenage years
since i got into goth i really
then this is completely honest i never
really
bothered myself with people sexual
orientation i really didn't yeah
i was just kind of like when i met
people i was like is this a cool person
do they like like cool music or they
like but and then i didn't like really
worry about
well you look man i didn't worry about
it even detroit then you go to the army
and i was in some of the nashville
scenes you know
off and on when i could but then coming
to boston hanging out in man race
sexual and gender identity just talking
about it was a faux pas
that was a social well it wasn't really
anything that anybody's
worried about and nobody's business and
like i said it was
it was all kind of like a [ __ ] goth
itself was kind of like a sexual
orientation to begin with
[ __ ] you weren't sp you weren't
supposed to
you weren't even supposed to [ __ ] you
were just sexual
it didn't really matter that's all it's
just kind of like if you like
you heard oh this chick like [ __ ] that
other chick or something
it was like yeah whatever no one's like
really no one really worried about it
it's like a [ __ ] nested damn
[ __ ] vampire bats it didn't really
[ __ ] matter
um like like i said [ __ ] it's just
oh man it was weird you know what i mean
and and the thing is is that it was like
it was uncool to even talk about
um orientation that was kind of like off
the table
in a way well because it's like i almost
kind of feel like you want to do nobody
cares about it yeah
it was something that no one really
considered the ship no one really
considered
it was just whether or not you were part
of the pack or not yeah and um
if you're into cool [ __ ] no one really
cared like who you slept with
and i was in there at that time hanging
out with a dude with long black hair
like this is that he was an ex-soviet
soldier
he was ex soviet infantry and i was the
ex-american infantry
i showed him to j his name was vadim
vadim kanyev and he was this [ __ ]
badass russian dude
who owned a [ __ ] computer comp a
little computer store
and he [ __ ] had a three a three-story
[ __ ] house
filled with [ __ ] strippers that's it
that lived with him
literally filled with strawberries
there's a stripper in every [ __ ] room
a stripper and everywhere they were yeah
they were renting rooms from him
he owned the house and [ __ ] around
the room and he was like tom i want you
to come work i just read a horror novel
yeah every time i want you to come work
for me you can live with me and the
girls and you can work at my place and
that was too much of a big shout out i
thought it wasn't just ah you couldn't
afford me you know i was a [ __ ]
corporate salesman [ __ ]
i should have [ __ ] done it because
[ __ ] the company closed about [ __ ]
a year later but by that time man too
much pride in me i wasn't gonna go
[ __ ] live with vadim and his horse
but [ __ ] i was just yeah i'm i'm
[ __ ] and they weren't horses they
were good girls
[Laughter]
but uh there were all these gothic
strippers out there
i should have done it probably had a lot
of fun time yeah you probably wouldn't
i want you to come work with me and this
and that but his company went out of
business eventually anyway it only
bought me a couple years
but uh i showed you pictures of him and
jamie was like oh he's cute
he looked like an antonio banderas
looked like a russian antonio barderas
[ __ ] all gothed out [ __ ] death
rock outfit and [ __ ]
and uh he was a [ __ ] trip man he's
getting all kinds of trouble he had he
was like one of the only dudes i knew in
boston it had a damn [ __ ] bronco 4x4
assault truck he had that [ __ ] it was
[ __ ] black
black with a red interior with red
[ __ ] lights inside you know like the
dome lights and all the [ __ ]
red it's like a vampire [ __ ] 4x4 nice
[Laughter]
yeah man is good he had assault rifles
and [ __ ]
but it's funny though because it kind of
seems like
i don't i don't want to like tutor our
own horn or anything
but it does kind of seem like even going
back to the 80s
the gothy and the club scene the new
wave new romantic all that kind of stuff
um i kind of feel like it wasn't a
thing like whatever your sexuality was
no one really like worried about it i
see some of these [ __ ] wokies [ __ ]
online today [ __ ] screeching about
their [ __ ] sexual
orientation and their identity and this
and that and go blowing it out of
proportion
no it's like that's that's cool it's
like they don't maybe they don't feel as
accepted as they used to
i'm like man [ __ ] we had marilyn
manson from growing up right but that
was a subculture
that was a subculture i'm just saying
that maybe we were like ahead of our
time because i kind of feel like in the
goth scene
from our point of view it was like kind
of lame nobody really gave a crap
well and honestly maybe that's why some
people are like
giving some pushback on that because
it's like for us it was never
we never cared so it's kind of like
we don't understand like why people have
to push back but they do have to push
back
you have to think that like we're cool
with it but that was like
you know going back to the 80s but that
was like a subculture
yeah that's not like mainstream culture
well our attitude was just [ __ ] the
mainstream culture they were
they were irrelevant that's what i'm
saying we had our own thing going that's
what i'm saying just didn't really care
that's what i'm saying so it's like it's
easy for us to say it's like what are
you whining about but it's like they
didn't
like grow up in the same subculture that
we did
well so it's not like it's easy for them
i'll go back to what
to what um toby said toby said he
doesn't like the mainstream casey and
just he just doesn't like it because
they're too much like regular people
he likes to [ __ ] hang out with freaks
like us and [ __ ] where he grew up
with and well yeah
i don't care who it is if you're a
weirdo like i want to like not a serial
killer but you know what i mean
our generation mainstream accept
acceptance
in our generation was something you
didn't want you weren't looking for
mainstream acceptance yeah you didn't
want to like you didn't want those
people to like accept you
yeah what the [ __ ] you talking about
that's so fun you want them to approve
of you
you wanted them to think you were a
weirdo exactly
exactly you know like no no no you
didn't want them
emulating or copying you not one bit you
wanted them to not well that's what i
mean that's why i
didn't like when all the [ __ ] like when
gosh [ __ ] went mainstream in like the
early 90s i talked about that on another
oh that was a big bummer
my friend pierre kicked marilyn manson
or would not allow marilyn manson into
the [ __ ] club i get that
he would like if i could join her in if
i owned a club i would not have lit
maryland yeah marilyn manson was [ __ ]
pissed
oh pissed perfect trent left with him
we're not coming in then and [ __ ]
everybody's like bye was like don't want
him in here
bye and he's i'm marilyn manson cause
yeah i know i don't want you yeah
we know who you are get out we were
catching so much flack
honestly i love that though yeah we were
catching so much flack in those days it
doesn't make any sense
probably to a person up today why would
you do that if you were there at the
time
now i just got bottles thrown at you and
people screamed marilyn manson at you
constantly yep and you didn't even
really listen to that i remember
waiting in line at the castle yeah and
having some like yuppie [ __ ]
behind me in line waiting to get in
and be like marilyn manson i'm like like
[ __ ] marilyn manson what are you even
like doing here nobody listens to that
what the [ __ ] are you been talking about
that's your music not ours yeah
like [ __ ] off nobody wants you in here
it's like you know what i mean so he did
have a couple of good songs he did
and it's you know we were just talking
about janet dimitri [ __ ] demetri and
marilyn manson
were friends they came up together down
in tampa wasn't it tampa
yeah they were dj's together well brian
warner brian warner brian warner which
is maryland
he's from here he's from central florida
so a lot of people that we know yeah
knew him back yeah but looking back on
it [ __ ] uh
thank you phil thank you what do you say
talking about sex late love you jenna
daddy tom
thank you we love you too but um brian
or also known as marilyn manson he
actually did really well in his time and
he did have some good songs i
uh they were i couldn't listen to his
whole album at the time they were too
hard
they were much harder than most goth
music we were listening to at that time
we were listening to a lot of stuff that
was kind of like dead can dance or
um [ __ ] uh what was that french band
uh die form i really liked that yeah
switchblade symphony
uh well there was a lot more
garden well 90s was a lot more like in
the gut scene it was a lot more like
ethereal
ethereal yeah was kind of like where the
well there was like
there were two factions it was kind of
like ethereal goth and then you had like
a harder like industrial goth
but even so like when marilyn manson
came out i'm like [ __ ]
uh you know skinny puppy throw kill kill
ministry
already did this stop so like why are
you doing it now
because i heard it well no he did it he
took
something that was good and repackaged
it for the mainstream sure
and made his name known and became
wealthy had he spent his money
correctly he'd still be wealthy i don't
think he still is anymore
i don't think he's relevant he might
come back but he's made some mistakes
lately he can't talk
he had a bad drug problem uh yeah big
time
um and i think that's really what but i
think that was one of the main things
that pissed me off
and you know adjacently that was another
thing that pissed me off about a lot of
like uh
indie bands that came out like in the
90s and stuff
i'm like dude you're just ripping off
stuff that happened in the 80s it was
like underground
but now you're taking it mainstream and
everyone's like talking about your
like you're the best thing since sliced
bread i'm like [ __ ]
like [ __ ] skinny puppy whoever have
been doing that since like 1981
so where have you guys been yeah
everybody's taught me the same thing
nobody asked and [ __ ] fourth throw
down they don't give a [ __ ] what your
orientation is or who you [ __ ] but
that's good i think that's awesome that
like everybody that is going toward that
because like i said i grew up in the 80s
um
where i was super into new wave and you
know the early 80s was a big
gender bending time you had like you
[ __ ] uh your rhythmics you had annie
lennox like dressed like a dude
you had boy george dressed like a woman
and it's like us
we're just kind of like what yeah that's
cool whatever it's like we didn't really
care about it
gen x we didn't care about it no um but
i grew up in a time when our
parents not so much my parents but like
my grandparents for sure
were kind of like are they gay they're
all on drugs they're all gay well they
had to put things in boxes back yeah and
it's just
kind of like why like who [ __ ] cares
why
like why do we care about that well they
were also real they were real
remember how like our parents and
grandparents generation were
they thought that what even what
that clothes and hair had some kind of
symbolic meaning
yes like well you what does that mean
you're okay you're wearing black what is
it i got yeah i got it
what does that mean like it doesn't mean
anything other than
i think it looks cool and it's because
their parents in
in the you know who would be our
grandparents for them it did
if you wore yellow on tuesday it meant
you were gay
i mean that's one of the things if you
wore black that meant that you were a
hood wait which
so it was never really fashioned for
fashion's sake
and it was never yeah you couldn't just
like dress styles like because you
thought it looked
no it had to mean something it had to
mean something right which i didn't
really get
i'm like it doesn't have to be any older
generations
i just thought it looked awesome it
doesn't really mean anything deeper than
that well you
you look at uh okay a mainstream a
mainstream one that they would know
would be like prince
prince was a little black dude [ __ ]
who had a dress and you had his [ __ ]
sing
well actually i'd call him probably
biracial really um
i think he i don't know what he
identified is i think he probably
identified as by eraser
but um baby i don't know i don't think
he ever brought it up it didn't really
matter
nobody cared and even his gender
identity nobody really cared
i'm older people would see him and go
well he's gay
but to me he was obviously [ __ ] an
aggressive heterosexual
uh yeah aggressively obviously so
they're
they're everyone said the members of
duran duran were gay too and i was just
kind of like uh
no those are like aggressively
heterosexual i don't know why you don't
like see that but okay no and nick
rhodes who would i guess superficially
be called the gayest looking one
was the [ __ ] main one he was the one
that
[ __ ] really totally would have hit
that yeah he was my second favorite
after simon
simon was my favorite and those dudes
only only dated supermodels
yeah so obviously yeah everyone didn't
have the same hang ups as
no you know i think he went back to
david bowie and we talked about this
earlier david bowie knew how to [ __ ]
with people
and it goes back to the new new york
dolls they knew how to [ __ ] with people
they were basically dressing as women
yeah for their time yep but those dudes
were all aggressively [ __ ]
heterosexual
and david bowie was a false homosexual
or a false bisexual he was [ __ ] a
closeted
straight he said that his dying words
was
tell them i was a closeted heterosexual
that's just so [ __ ] some of the best
[ __ ] funniest even if he didn't say
that
even if that's not true it should be
true he said it
you said it because that's that's tell
them i was
what's the name iman said that iman said
his final words was
were tell them i was a closeted
heterosexual
wait what's his name um
uh what's his name uh mick ronson or
mick mick ronson isn't his name the
guitar player
from from uh the old david bowie years
the 70s years
he said the same thing he said he
he said he knew how to talk to to
to powerful and wealthy gay men
who helped finance his art projects he
had a lot of gay friends
but he said it was it was it was fake he
wasn't gay he was straight
he was straight but like i said does
that really i don't care
i don't know it didn't it didn't matter
and honestly i feel like
he was promoting an idea and a [ __ ]
visual of
in a visual idea that was popular with
the gay art scene
and they helped him
because if i guess you could say it
furthered acceptance
it did well that's the kind of thing
it's like i kind of feel like that was
maybe why i mean growing up for me i was
like kind of privileged in a way because
it's like i got into the goth scene
where
because i never really saw the point of
differentiating
i was just kind of like man people just
like sleep with whoever
like do what you want to do it's not in
my business obviously so it's like
do what you want and i liked that about
the goth scene was that that was
something that really wasn't
brought up yeah you know it was just
kind of like
hey you know that you know other than
like seeing gossip like oh my god can
you believe like
she like [ __ ] that dude and like
whatever and it's like there was that
kind of thing but it's like nobody
really cared about
anything beyond that it was just kind of
like no one really gave a [ __ ] about
what orientation you were if you're just
like oh i [ __ ] a dude i [ __ ] a woman
it's like no one really cared about it
and it's like i liked that because like
i said it's no one's business
yeah so i didn't really and even going
back to the 80s when i was a kid
and like i said you know early 80s new
wave was very
uh gender bending so it was something
visually it was visually and we kind of
got like used to it so it's like it was
not a big deal
right and no one really like bothered
about it because some of those dudes
were straight some of them were gay and
like no one really bothered they were
just having fun
no one really bothered about it like was
the music cool okay
that's all anyone really cared about
well you know the the queen
song uh what is it i'd like to be like
to be free
wasn't the name of the song he's
obviously in drag with the mustache on
doing doing doing housework and that was
just something that played on television
and that
didn't cause any kind of big stink i
mean not with us anyway
like with older people he played that
[ __ ] [ __ ] on cable
night tracks in mississippi and nobody
noticed it
yeah i saw it yeah people did not care
um
you hear these kids running around today
talking as if 10 years ago was the dark
ages
they do not understand how sexually
[ __ ] free the 70s and the 60s were
it was nobody gave a [ __ ] nobody gets i
mean when you got into the 80s you have
to admit
like [ __ ] didn't get shown on tv or
movies like everyone was like uptight
about it
that wasn't us that was older they had
sensor
sensors right that was an awesome stuff
yeah they had a group of people called
sensors that censored things for
television
but that wasn't the normal person
because so like okay so we were
let's have an example we were at
mannequins yeah and he played
uh the cramps song creature from the
black leather lagoon
yes creatures from the block which has
kind of a dirty video
yeah no nudity but there's a lot of
uh very very implied like s m
there's a lot of like it's very very
sexual there's a lot like lux interior
has the
yeah lux interior is dressed like a
[ __ ] rockabilly with a leather jacket
he has like a little
thing he's got nothing like the leather
it's a g-string and women's [ __ ]
black
pvc pumps on yes and his guitar
yeah and he's skinny as [ __ ] look at the
picture from the black leather lagoon
and he's been attacked by a damn uh-huh
and his guitar player poison ivy who is
his wife
yeah uh who's in a leopard print thing
he's [ __ ]
doing sexual [ __ ] i love guitar i have
to say
and you see it today and it's just funny
you can see it for
it is a funny you understand what it is
that he's doing
he's he's riffing on the 1950s he's
riffing on monster movies
he's riffing on well that was kind of
their whole thing
his 50s he's riffing on crossdressing
sure he's [ __ ] which
it probably he's probably talking about
ed wood
uh i think it doesn't matter
like i said the new york dolls had been
doing that in their early 70s just like
crossdressing all that guy they are
[ __ ] with you
yeah they're [ __ ] with you well that
[ __ ] was banned we never saw that on
television because they wouldn't play
that nope
but if you see it today you just see it
for what it is it was just a joke
although it's still awesome it's [ __ ]
awesome yeah but it's [ __ ] fun i love
that video but back in the days the
sensors would have go oh no we can't we
can't
we can't show that well why today you
look at you go why not
that's [ __ ] hilarious he's obviously
[ __ ] joking around you know what i
mean and
they're yeah in a 50s [ __ ] dude it's
like a 50s monster movie master movie
with [ __ ] weird gender bending things
but with lux interior wearing and
wearing women's
g-string and yeah and women's shoes yeah
sure
and luck's interior could [ __ ] pull
it off man yeah and he was straight
he was he's straight well yeah his wife
is playing guards poison ivy they were
married a long time
but they're just [ __ ] with you and
they they didn't understand that kind of
[ __ ] back then
well like i'm saying it's like it was
just funny and it was funny because
older but like i said our parents
generation our grandparents actually
would get
so upset about it because they thought
it meant something that it was
funny yeah to just like push it in their
faces
yeah that's why you guys can open
another window and go look at it man
called the cramps
creature from the black leather it's a
good song dude i love the [ __ ] crazy
it's punkabilly it's like rockabilly but
it's [ __ ] kind of psychobilly isn't
it like abilities
i mean the cramps were kind of like um
i kind of feel like they were the first
band that they might have
they might have coined the term
psychobilly it was kind of like the
misfits or kind of like the stray cats
they were super into 50s rock and roll
yeah and 50s monster movies
yeah but with a little bit of an 80s
sensibility
yeah i mean if you haven't heard the
cramps you really need luxe interior
sadly
uh passed away several years ago i saw
them live
when did i see them 2008
i want to say maybe tila says oh my god
they were fantastic tina says to tammy i
don't even know goth culture but i
relate to you all on a whole nother
level which is rare
yeah if you go back in time
goth people were the black people of
white people in a certain way
we were the black people of white people
oh my god are you sure are you sure you
want to make those statements
we were the black people of white well
kind of misunderstood and under attack
there are a lot of misunderstandings
not so much nowadays not as bad as it
was but back in the old days not as bad
as it was sure
there was a lot of misconceptions about
what we were about they project a lot of
[ __ ] on us
uh there weren't very many of us it was
a small [ __ ] click
um we had a lot of art to it to we had a
lot of artistic stuff to offer the
mainstream
in terms of fashion and music and
culture and those [ __ ] eventually
adopted it
they are [ __ ] they culturally
appropriated a lot of [ __ ]
they did from what we do which like i
said kind of pisses me off not gonna lie
not gonna lie there is [ __ ] that we
would be wearing and only we would wear
it
and 10 years later those [ __ ] were
wearing it and then i'm like
wait [ __ ] man now i can't wear that
anymore they culturally appropriated
ourselves they did
yeah they did yeah i mean
it's weird because like i've been
dressing like this for like 15 years
and then i'd be at the mall and like
some dude would be like
matrix maybe like or you know
beetlejuice
yeah they would point at me and yell at
that i'm like [ __ ] do you know how long
that i have looked like this
yeah do you know that like people of my
generation
right like people my age are making that
movie is that why
like you know what i mean i don't know
i mean i guess my point there is like
don't yell random [ __ ] at goths in the
mall
because they're not gonna be happy about
it yeah
i mean i had that happen several times i
had not so much i had
beetlejuice yelled at me a couple times
matrix yelled at me many times
um but i was just kind of like and you
know what i didn't even like the matrix
i didn't like that movie i liked it i
thought it was i saw that movie and i'm
like man seen it
no at the time that i saw it it was very
innovative
and it was but like i don't know i just
kind of feel like
it was another thing where i had been
into this [ __ ] for since the early 80s
and by the time that came out i was just
kind of like oh you guys are now
discovering this yay now you're gonna
like now everybody's gonna be into this
[ __ ] and i don't like it so
i was just mad i don't know i was mad
about it
mad about it i was the same way that i
was like mad when
you know underground like alternative
music went mainstream like in 91 [ __ ]
nirvana i still blame them for that
but it's just like that whole thing oh
now everybody knows who the pixies are
goody i don't know it used to be cool
and now a lot of like douchebags are in
our [ __ ] great yeah
great now i gotta like contend with this
at the [ __ ] clubs now
so how long we've been streaming three
hours
man this has been a good show what did
we even talk about for three hours we
talked about everything for three hours
did we yeah look at you i know i'm
getting prettier and prettier as time
goes on you already said beautiful i
can't understand it just i'm gonna take
this off i gotta
turn back into my ugly ass
yeah put on put one of my wigs on no
it's getting hot man i'm getting hot no
i'm done with the wigs oh my god he
makes me wear wigs all the time
see i told like i think you were in the
bathroom when i said but i was like
i'm kind of tempted to like shave my
head but no don't shave it it's good
no you got a good mohawk that looks cool
he told me my head would look too fat
i didn't say that well that's kind of
what you said i do kind of like the
mohawk though no it looks good
because we can push that up here up here
in the front yeah
because i did like kind of tease it in
the back a bit long in certain areas i
can cut the top of it to make it shorter
because see the thing is if i want to
tease it up because i can
but i can do that and it would look
awesome
but then the next day i'd be like why
why did i do this
then i have to comb all the knots out
that's the only thing about
it it's fun it looks cool it's going up
on eight o'clock i think we ought to let
the people go
you think yeah plus we got [ __ ] we can
watch and
watch some [ __ ] movies watch some
[ __ ] movies watch a movie
you guys have fun tonight let me finish
hopefully you guys have fun
hopefully everybody had enough to drink
[Laughter]
he's going to push him one more okay you
want another one
i haven't even had one but yeah i would
like one smoked one
i don't like these as much as i liked
the menthol ones
but i have to admit i didn't buy any
more because
when we got them and i smoked one at the
bar
and the bartender said it smells like
dead fish in here yeah yeah
like not knowing what it is smell that
good they don't smell that good they
taste all right though
yeah i kind of watched them cbd
cigarettes too
and um they were [ __ ] expensive
twenty dollars a pack
too expensive smoke i tell you what
though they don't
it's not like weed these herbal ones are
only like
four bucks yeah i get the money but they
kind of chill you out kind of in the
opposite way that a cigarette might kind
of amp you up a little bit the cbd
cigarettes will kind of like go
chill you out for a few seconds and then
weak like a cigarette but it's just
weird
i you know i i have never had that
reaction
yeah when i smoked them i never feel any
different
right i was like want to
that was like why why i smoked pot like
a couple times before because i thought
that it would chill me out because i
need that
yeah that's just that she's looking
forward to the friday night show
we're gonna have a good show on friday
like i said it's gonna be about feral
children
yeah tammy said tammy said this is a
great show tila saying good night
we're gonna be out for a few seconds
we're gonna smoke one cigarette with you
and then we're gonna close out
i can't believe we were three hours yeah
but you know yeah but that's the thing
it's like i always
i was kind of like i'm not like a
druggie but i always kind of like
tried different things hoping that it
would like
chill me out you know what i mean
because i need that
one i overthink everything which in a in
a lot of ways isn't it bad because i
keep
all my [ __ ] together which is good go
ahead and hit the like button people if
you can
yeah everybody and comment too like
later because that like makes you yeah
comment also later
but um i don't know it's like i just
kind of feel like nothing
the few times i smoke pot it just made
me like feel worth like it made me feel
like even more
like paranoid and more like um
you know self-conscious i don't really
like weed and i don't i
don't like that like maybe i just like
smoked the wrong thing
but i was like i want something that
makes me feel
less self-conscious thumbs up we're
going up going up thank you very much
thank you very much went up a couple
yeah less self-conscious less because
i'm super self-conscious
even we're at the club um
and even if i know everybody i have to
drink a lot
before i'll start dancing and i can
dance i'm not a bad dancer like
you know what i mean i'm not a bad dad
bad dancer right i'm a good dancer i
think you don't need a drink to dance
but it's the way you're thinking about
it thank you very much yeah that's what
i'm saying
that's what i'm saying and it's like
some especially if
um like sometimes a song come on and i
love that song
but nobody's dancing and i was like man
i'm gonna feel so [ __ ] awkward if i'm
the only one out there like every now
and then i'll go out there if i'm
if i've had it she's full of [ __ ] she'll
be the only person out there dancing
first yeah but the whole time just
you're drunk you'd be out there to be
the first person yeah but the whole time
yeah my in my head i'm like do i look
like a dog you can't tell
do i look like a dork i cannot wait for
friday i'm healing up after my accent
accident to get to start pt next week
but doing great here love this group
thank you very much
victor garcia he had a very important
observation he said
smoking marijuana made me gay victor mad
[ __ ] your insight said to the [ __ ]
[ __ ] outstanding right yeah
[Laughter]
gadget says thanks podcast guys love you
13 podcasts love you both thank you very
much gabby we love you too
david junius is a great group of folks
it is we really have like a nice
okay we really have a nice like uh yes
you know
it's a small little family there i know
i love it
this is the only show that we do that i
don't feel stressed out
because i don't have to do any research
just talk i don't do anything we can
just hang out and i know that if i
don't like think of [ __ ] to say you will
like talk for ages right
and well we got feedback from the
audience too and then yeah and like i
can interact with you guys and then like
after a couple of drinks i won't give a
[ __ ] anymore
yeah so you know that's why like i said
i'm not drunk or anything but
people hitting the thumbs up thank you
very much i still see thumbs up is going
up
that's great hit it if you guys didn't
hit it
okay
i'm still mad that when we were at
mannequins when they played that crime
song that i didn't go dance
because it was early i wasn't drunk
enough no one was dancing
i thought about it and i didn't later he
played alien sex fiend and i was like
okay well i can't just stand here
anymore
i have to go dance to this yeah victor
garcia said first time i messed around
with a dude in high school we were both
stoned uh yeah i did man [ __ ] weed
made you gay bro
you've made you gay it happened in the
god scene it wasn't cool for anybody to
know what orientation you were you
weren't even supposed to talk about it
you're supposed to let everybody [ __ ]
guess it was supposed to just like stay
like
yeah you're like we were all like
cryptic yeah you're not supposed to know
supposed to hide the [ __ ] yeah you had
to look like an
equal opportunity action giver yeah i
kind of feel like the goth scene
and honestly like even like the dead
milkman and stuff like that like even
made jokes about this
uh in their song uh instant club you'll
dance anything i'm just another boring
bisexual
because that was kind of like what the
god scene was like at the time
everyone just wanted everybody to think
they were bisexual yeah then later
i'll just sleep with anybody yeah after
that you had to say no we're not sexual
or or whatever we're not an orientation
it's just something's going to happen
cause you don't know
once the [ __ ] gets played out [ __ ] will
get played out
it's better to be [ __ ] unknown as you
know what i mean where you
honestly i think that's better it's
better it's like shredding your
sexuality yeah yeah
i kind of feel like everybody well and
honestly everybody should approach
things that way because you never know
when you're going to meet a person
right whatever orientation they are
that's really going to click with you
well that's what bowie was talking about
that's what i'm saying that's a bug
honestly i figured that out when i was
like a teenager
and i was just kind of like that's kind
of you just meet somebody and it's like
if you click with that person and you
want to sleep with that person it's just
sleep with that person it doesn't matter
like what [ __ ]
gender or whatever it doesn't matter
what they are doesn't matter it's funny
it
kind of goes into a mobius strip though
because [ __ ] boy was doing that but
he was straight
it just he was just saying keep your
mind open
well that's on one time keep your mind
though i mean you can identify as
straight but it's like
every now and then you might meet a
person like i mostly identify as
straight but
sometimes you meet a person you're just
like grandpa's going emos
gay goths or just effeminate ambiguous
gods
just ambiguous i kind of feel like the
the god sexuality is ambiguous
and ambiguous all around ambiguous on
purpose
yeah it's it's ambiguous
we'll just kind of we're just sitting
back waiting to see
what excites us what excites us we're
not
concerned about what it is we're just
waiting for it to happen most of them
were straight though
well yeah yeah but part of the [ __ ]
part of the game it was part of the game
but like i said you just kind of like
yeah it's probably good
you weren't like close to it no if
something came along
that was like not what you would usually
do but that was still kind of compelling
you were like all right
most of most of the girls would mess
around
um some of the guys were [ __ ] gay
some of the guys would mess around most
of the guys were straight
but you had to keep all that [ __ ] close
to close to your vest
you didn't want to [ __ ] be
pigeonholed as anything because that
just wasn't cool back in those days
everything had to be mysterious you had
to get even though they [ __ ] saw you
with girls
they saw you they saw what you were
doing but that wasn't proof
you know what i mean well because you
could be doing other stuff
without that's what i'm saying i don't
know
because like i said it was all kind of
like you were just like sitting back
yeah and watching for something you
never knew
when something compelling was going to
come along that's what i'm saying
you just had to keep like here's the
[ __ ] weird thing about how to keep
your shot at the scene
is that if you weren't a goth you were
excluded you were off the menu well
that's what i mean
only god between gods like that's what i
was saying it was like
it was like a sexual orientation until
itself
you couldn't go out with a mundane you'd
get excommunicated
yeah everybody's like what the [ __ ] you
don't [ __ ] with that thing yeah
no well that would be considered like a
[ __ ]
really bad [ __ ] interracial
relationship back in the 50s or
something
i mean i think that's why i think maybe
that's why i related to like some of the
john hughes movies like pretty in pink
or
uh some kind of wonderful because that
kind of dealt with
people that were like into the
alternative scene like dating
like crossing the divide yeah and going
over to [ __ ] and
like dating like a yuppie and something
and like everybody be like oh no
oh no let's let's not do that so i kind
of like the way that like pretty in pink
kind of like even though she ended up
with him which kind of sucked i don't
like that
because he was let's be real like kind
of a douche bag
but i mean you know ducky was kind of a
douchebag too but not as much
it was you know it was a spectrum um
but i kind of feel like i like that they
at least
uh addressed that yeah because like he
she brings the yuppie to like the
underground like the punk club or
whatever and everyone's like oh [ __ ] oh
no all right grantham says are some goth
guys
wolves in sheep clothings acting gay
only to deceive girls that later get in
their pants
yes hell yes and i knew one of them he
was a dude from [ __ ]
uh sweden he was cool as [ __ ]
he never claimed to be gay he just kind
of had
effeminate ways okay i never really
experienced
which that doesn't that doesn't
necessarily firsthand now
he he was a big tall good-looking goth
guy who had
very effeminate ways he dressed like a
dude though
if you didn't know what was going on you
might think he was gay
but he was a hound man but here's the
thing
he's not pretending to be gay to get
girls
he's just being that way and girls are
coming to him
yeah you know what i mean yeah he never
made the claim
yeah he never made the claim of being
gay or anything or never
like well i'm gonna add gay no he just
is very
effeminate in kind of his ways and his
look
he was very much into like 1700s looking
fashion and [ __ ]
he was wearing men's clothing and
[ __ ] like 1700s makeup and the white
wigs
and the [ __ ] suits and [ __ ] very much
kind of like this dandy you know what i
mean
but no the [ __ ] girls loved him
you're talking about and he was a hound
and he had money he had money you know
he bought all that [ __ ] before he showed
up to boston yeah
well i mean like i said you know when
they're gonna be attracted to
a dude that pays that much attention to
what they look like how they dance it's
like because they put an effort in
right i guess you could say in those
chicks like dudes that make it
dudes back in those days would have
thought he was gay
yeah but the goth girls didn't they no
they they knew what he was doing no you
wouldn't um a goth girl would not assume
they wouldn't assume
no
you wouldn't assume that um unless you
knew him personally
and you knew that he was gay yeah if you
just saw him
looking like that you would not assume
that i mean that goth wouldn't
no no but but a non-goth would
probably he would get like oh you know
dude's [ __ ] making fun of him and
[ __ ] yeah and i was like dude
no he's not we would know he's not even
know better he's knocking down girls
you're [ __ ] paying to see in
magazines
[ __ ] you know yeah like i said we
would know better i would not assume
i would not assume anyone's sexuality
just by what they look like i'm trying
to translate and other
cultural [ __ ] motifs
you know what i mean it's way we see it
is not the way you see it because we
we've been in the game
for [ __ ] 30 40 30 years you know more
30 something years things are not as
they appear
yeah i would never assume someone's
sexuality from what they look like never
nope nope i mean because you can't tell
nope
nope you'd run across some girl you
swear to god that's a butch
and no it's not it's a straight girl but
she just wouldn't think that
that was her thing that was rare that
was the boston thing there was a girl
that
looked like a kind of like a
bdsm [ __ ] dominatrix butch
kind of kind of like jen from jana
torturers but more
kind of masculine looking she was
straight as hell
yeah but tough see that's what i mean i
would never assume
yeah you i would never assume but a
straight person probably would
yeah they probably would yeah but i
never would i call them straight of
mundane
yeah would probably think that that was
a lesbian no
not at all but like i said that was one
thing i always liked about
uh the god seeing him going back to the
80s is that
there was just everyone just kind of
dressed the way they wanted and no one
assumed anything about their sexuality
you know what i mean it just wasn't
nobody said hey you're this or hey
you're that
everyone just like kind of took you as
you were which
i i kind of feel like you should do with
all people it was honestly it was all
just a group of friends
that have fun with each other that
really in the end didn't take a lot of
this [ __ ] seriously
there were cultural rules that you
really weren't supposed to break
but in the 70s this was still going on
in places like
england in the same scene that brought
out
the sex pistols and billy idol and susie
and
it was a scene like that or or seemed
kind of like studio 54 in new york but
that was more disco
this was a similar scene but going into
a different direction it was the goth
scene
and it was kind of better when it was a
smaller scene
and kind of new and a little bit
exclusive
well you kind of knew everybody knew at
least it's second hand
and you couldn't just show up and get
into these clubs they'd look at you at
the door and go
we can't let you in not just like that
nowadays in most places they'll let
anybody in
but back in the day like a man race if
you just didn't fit the part they were
you weren't going to get in
well because the thing you had to
realize was that
um you know back in the day the gutsy
and it was just like gay clubs and stuff
like that you couldn't just let anybody
in because you didn't know if they were
gonna cause trouble
yeah um you didn't know if this was like
some person that was gonna like go in
there like start beating people up or
something like that
and in boston there was minim there was
there in boston there was
a maximum capacity so you couldn't let a
mundane in
when goths were trying to get in yeah
because once it got up to massive
maximum capacity you couldn't let any
more any more people and the thing about
it too
is that you know if we're calling them
some people weren't told they couldn't
come in
some people were saying you have to wait
here yeah and talk about until everybody
else gets falling
and now it's full and then they go okay
we can take 20.
get 20 of those you can goodman and i
mean the thing about it too is that
particularly i think there's a lot of
overlap here between the goth scene and
the gay scene but like going back
to the old days um sometimes
clubs were the only place you felt safe
yeah and there was no internet so the
club was our version of social media
that's what i mean so that's kind of
the only place you could get together
with other people and you you knew that
you weren't going to get picked on
um you could like meet other people that
were the same as you
so it's kind of like you didn't want a
lot of like
people that would normally pick on you
like normal people like
um invading that space you know what i'm
saying so it was like a similar kind of
thing
so for a time there were dress codes
like to keep those people out
she's referring the south the northeast
wasn't like that well yeah the south was
kind of okay
in the northeast people wouldn't pick on
goths
down here they did yeah no up north they
didn't give a [ __ ]
um you might have some people laugh at
you but that's not the same as picking
on you
um it's just so it's a different scene
than what she's talking about
like in in the 90s the god
the goth scene was looking pretty
exclusive people were people kind of
wanted to go in it if
even if they knew about it the people
that knew about it wanted to go see it
but they couldn't let them in because
you had it
the clubs were only a certain size once
it was filled to capacity
you couldn't let any more people in yeah
and there were enough goths to
almost kind of halfway or three quarters
of the capacity to fill it
and the mundanes were let in after all
the [ __ ] regulars had shown up
yeah basically that's what it was so
that was kind of what was going on in
studio 54
back back in the disco days you had to
be dressed a certain way all the
regulars went in first
and then they'd go down through the line
if there was space left we'll take that
one and we'll take her
yeah do you look okay yeah yeah because
they'll only take a certain amount of
people because you can't
you can't fit everybody they won't fit
in there well and there are some people
that you know are probably
right you don't want to let in right
yeah well yeah so some of them they'll
just kick away
no no no no go fight somewhere else you
now we're not letting you guys in we'll
see you next time but all the happy
girls or the guys yes because hot girls
i mean that's going to bring in like
other people that's always a good thing
to have in your
club and to be honest with you like
you know girls are probably not going to
cause as much trouble as dudes yeah
just saying right um but one thing that
used to piss me off about like the
castle back in the day
was that i kind of felt like when they
let
normal people in which they did
sometimes not a lot because
um back when i used to go like you know
there wasn't
um no you know nowadays in ebor city
there's this huge [ __ ]
there's all these restaurants and other
clubs like right there the castle used
to be a little bit
like off the beaten path so you didn't
get so many people just like wandering
in because
not a lot of people came down that way
but
i used it used to make me mad because
i'm like [ __ ] it's like
you like normal people i guess it's like
you have all these clubs i mean ebor
city like seventh avenue
that you have all these clubs you can go
to we have one
like why do you want to let come and
invade ours
when we're here like having a good time
and you come in here and you're like
making fun of us and stuff and it's just
kind of like man we had one place
you guys have all these places you can
go that's there's your meat market
there's your dish you can do whatever
you want to do why you gotta link invade
this one place this is the only place
that we have yeah
and that used to like really really make
me angry that's why i didn't like them
in there
that's a southern experience yeah i
didn't really have that up north you
know i mean by the time i came
to the south uh goth had been around for
so long it became a fixture so
the problems are not they're the
problems we used to have in the 90s i
mean
it's there anymore it's not the same now
as it used to be
and honestly when i was growing up like
like i said i grew up in the south so it
was a probably a lot different than what
you experienced
um you know but we just we didn't have
you know uh us weirdos didn't have all
that many places to hang out
yeah so it's kind of and normally you've
got a bunch of places to hang out they
they have like endless nightclubs you
could go to just go to one of those
why do you want to come to this place
and [ __ ] with us when this is the only
place that we have like to have a good
time and not get laughed at for a change
and it was just kind of like so that was
another thing that kind of like fueled
us being angry about it that's all okay
so i think we've been on long enough and
we finished this cigarette it's time to
shut this [ __ ] down jenny people are
[ __ ] starting to uh
go ahead and sally out of here anyway so
all right and i gotta i probably
and probably we should get some food
yeah i kind of feel like i'm kind of
hungry so go ahead and hit that like
button if you haven't done that go ahead
and hit the like share like
like share and subscribe and we will be
back here
um when's our next show friday friday
we are doing a show about feral children
we do fair children
we'll drink again we'll talk about the
feral children it'll be cool so
we'll see you guys next friday yeah
friday night at 6 00 pm
thanks everybody for dropping by thanks
for super chats uh thanks for hanging
out with us on this wednesday night
hopefully we're
pretty coherent have a nice night we'll
see you guys friday evening
and we'll be back then bye